hello everybody
welcome john perry here i am with dr
joshua swamithas
and we are going to talk about his book
the genealogical adam and eve
and his
his history with this conflict that
exists between
science and religion and his
oh i i suppose proposed solution
so what do we call it i mean maybe i
mean i think
i just want to get the science straight
and make space for our differences and
yeah just be truthful another and trying
to figure it out together right
yeah yeah now uh
why so you're a christian and just
for the audience sciences too right yeah
yeah you're a christian you're a
scientist
i am actually a science educator i'm not
a scientist
and i happen to be an atheist uh it's
it's not really
uh hasn't been a big i wouldn't say that
i'm an anti-theist
and some people some people tell me that
i'm more accurately defined as an
agnostic uh because of that but
the i i do think it's it's good to just
like
put down our our you know positions here
before we
dive into this because i have been
teaching evolution now
genetics evolution and chemistry now
since 2011
and i do a lot of work in classrooms
mainly what i do is i make materials for
teachers to use in their classrooms but
i go into classrooms all the time to
you know see how it's working and just
one of the
most obvious problems that i find is
that
religious students have they're
under actual like stress real anxiety
is is overwhelming them when they start
learning about evolution because they've
been told
that it's a violation of their faith and
they're at school and they're forced to
learn it
and it's super uncomfortable for them
and
uh in the past what i've done i've found
biologos to be
really helpful i just i'll just tell
students when they when they try and
interrupt a discussion because
some some will just be quiet and kind of
hurt injured by
the fact that we're we're learning about
evolution others will get angry and try
and disrupt the class
and what i've found is really helpful is
to just you know
tell them that biologos exists and that
there are christians out there that have
found ways to accept evolution and
maintain their
religious beliefs and
pretty much every time that's calmed
things down so that we can continue with
the class
but i know that there's there's uh
there's real
like anxiety that's happening here
people can't think properly
when they're hit with this type of
anxiety
and so trying to find a way to uh
for students especially like middle
school high school students to
to find a way that they can learn this
without being feeling like they're being
assaulted
is super important to me which is why
i've been so interested in your
your book i mean you actually reached
out to me but as soon as i saw what
you're doing i got really excited so
um but my first question is why do you
think it's important for christians to
consider
evolution
well there's several pragmatic reasons
to consider it even if you think it's
wrong one is a lot of people think it's
true
and so um even if you're convinced it's
wrong
uh it seems like it would make sense to
understand how people you talk to about
your faith
might come to faith even if they stole
it from evolution
you know i think it's possible to follow
jesus even if they're wrong about
origins
so for that reason alone it's worth
understanding um
second reason um is once again because
it's out there is to follow proverbs 4 7
it says the first thing to do is really
understand stuff
you know before anything else try to
understand it so often
um when i was a christian i knew from
the start that i opposed evolution but i
didn't really understand it
um and that that wasn't really wise i
think
a better wiser approach is to start my
understanding
and even if i know i'm going to disagree
really understand
and i guess the last reason why is that
you know
there is a deep tradition in
christianity of realizing that uh what
we think about theology
what we think of what we read in
scripture has some bearing on the real
physical world that we all inherit it's
really about reality
and that's what um is part of the
impetus behind
the origin of science too about this
exchange between theology
and and inappropriate to try and really
hatch out what's really going on in
reality
um and there was conflicts back then
like about you know
about for example what about the earth
was stationary or not
and so i think it's a return to uh you
know the christian tradition
to uh instead of taking an oppositional
view to science to be in a more um
conversational back and forth or realize
that science
has legitimacy and certainly scripture
and theology is legitimacy too
it's not that one rule overrules the
other but they're supposed to be in
conversation with one another and that
is a return to the christian tradition
what ways do you think that this
historical conflict because
the conflict between evolution and
christianity specifically
has existed since darwin and uh maybe
before darwin when you had like earlier
versions of evolution being proposed uh
and it was it it immediately got really
sour
like right after the publish
the origin of species was published you
had the huxley doing debates
and stuff and they got pretty like
pretty personal and pretty brutal
and it seems like that tradition has
just continued until today i mean we
still have
it's in your in your book hold on let me
let me
let me quote your book so this is from
the genealogical adam and eve
the surprising science of universal
ancestry
and you say the question of human origin
sits at one fracture in society where
divisions
have grown into injuries and i see
that people come into this conversation
already injured
already angry already like ready to
fight
and it makes i mean i just publish this
animation on um
the you know the some of the genetic
evidence for evolution
and people in the comments are saying
things
so like the creationists will come in
and say things that are
like it's like they didn't they didn't
just watch the video that
they're commenting on stuff that's
completely irrelevant
and this is because i
i believe because of the stress the
injury the anger they come into looking
at it they can't even
listen to a five-minute you know
10-minute video and actually understand
what was said in it
because they came in pre-injured
and and you do see this happening on
both sides as well
of this of this argument there's there
definitely are injuries here
but what do you think are the uh
you know the how has this conflict
between evolution and christianity how
does it hurt both the science
and the uh the theology side of things
well it's important first when you think
about that history and learning what
that history is really helpful
um if you go back to when the words in
the species was really
really first proposed it wasn't about
the age of the earth that was
controversial that wasn't it
that just wasn't it it wasn't um
about uh about evolution in the animal
kingdom that was that was the problem
actually people had no problem with that
speaking um that just wasn't an issue
and then you keep in mind that origin
and species doesn't even
talk about anything other it doesn't
talk about what the real conflict is
so what the real conflict is is really
probably two things
one is um human evolution and so you
mentioned the huxley owens debates right
and so huxley owns debates is where
right immediately after
um huxley you know rushed in or
darwin feared to tread to talk about
human evolution
right that ended up being a really
controversial point because that seemed
to come into direct conflict with what
scripture said and what our instinct
our own origins are and our distinction
from
the rest of the created order or the
animal kingdom
and that was where an immense amount of
conflict was the other thing was
a really key thing was and actually once
again was a key part of that there was
others
especially during the 17th century um
that really put a strong emphasis on
emphasizing that there were no miracles
and that was by purely natural
godless atheistic prophets and so they
really tried to present
evolution as you know part and parcel
with atheism
that um that is one way to view
evolution
i mean certainly evolution can fit in an
atheistic
point of view but that wasn't the only
view i mean asa gray
was um one of the foremost proponents of
quote-unquote darwinism
in in you know in the united states
right afterwards he was a plant
biologist
and he was a christian and he wrote he
wrote about that a great deal
and it's just that that's not what the
dominant narrative became so it was
really
about how it was spun publicly and human
evolution the substantive issue was
human evolution
but the way it was spun publicly was as
atheism
and so that ended up really going
through to create
um you know those of conflicts that
we're still dealing with
to this day yeah yeah it is worth noting
that there's lots of
lots of christians who've already dealt
with this and kind of gotten over it
so that the catholic church has come out
pretty much
like i think it's an official uh you
know
the pokemon yeah yeah the pope is okay
with evolution i think there's
they have reservations about humans
humans have to be special
somehow in that but i don't think it's
super clear how
um well so that's that's actually a key
part so they
the key doctrine they have is
monogenesis that all humans have to
arise from
an original couple adam and eve yeah
yeah and now there are there are some
people on the fringes
of catholicism uh we disagree with that
i mean catholicism also tolerates
disagreement
on things like this too in a way that um
that's important to recognize but the
bulk of catholicism has really
emphasized
monogenesis and that's what makes i
think a lot of the conversation about do
we descend from adam and eve really
important
so the last 10 years some
biologists have made very strong um
claims that monogenesis the idea that we
all defend from adam and eve
has just been ruled out by the science
with one quote from dennis venema
a logos who argued that he was on it he
was interviewed by npr i think it was
and he says you know
i think the quote was you know asked
whether or not uh
we all sent from adam and eve uh dennis
responded
that would be against all of the
evidence we've collected in
you know in genomics and genetics so not
very likely
that's what he said and um that was in a
christianity today article
and this really created a lot of
conflict for a lot of people because a
lot of
uh christians not all but but many
christians have come to the returns of
the idea that maybe anatomy you've had
an appearance
but monogenesis is so important and
really um the key
argument that was being put forward is
well actually you got to let go of that
doctrine too
um and and that's what they were pushing
and that's why this question uh starts
to become important
because the catholic church was very
clear if that was a key doctrine that
was important but that was what a lot of
people in the public sphere were saying
was not actually consistent with
evidence
yeah yeah so yeah we'll talk about your
um
what what your view is later but i i
want to kind of i want to poke at this
like kind of the nature of the conflict
right now that exists between
between science and evolution sorry
between christianity and evolution in
general because
so we have a we have a pretty long
history now of
certain religious groups christian
groups being okay with it
they've come to become okay with it in
very different ways
i was raised mormon so um and
you know i actually i didn't i didn't
leave my religion until
later on in life actually was a mormon
missionary in sao paulo brazil
so i was i was in it until i was you
know
until my early 20s but the
did you end up marrying um a mormon no
no no that's uh that's why i had
something really hard to leave a lot of
times so
yeah yeah no i was i was uh i left
when i was actually went to byu and i i
left
my religion when i was in college before
i got married
that made it easier but the uh
i i had a sunday school teacher when i
was probably
five years old somewhere around there
who was a young earth creationist but
that's actually super rare for mormons
um but she told me that i was going to
learn about evolution and it was going
to be uh
you know the scientists were going to
try and trick me to stop believing god
and and whatnot so i was terrified i
remember when
i was in kindergarten they said we're
gonna do science about dinosaurs and i
was terrified
i thought that oh science my sunday
school teacher told me that science is
bad so i had this
just like sickening feeling in my
stomach
as a little kid like we're gonna learn
about dinosaurs i don't know
and i had uh so i had that anxiety but i
was also
i loved biology i mean my dog was
like the coolest thing for me and i
noticed that my dog had the same bones
that i have
he had shoulder blades on his his front
legs are actually arms
and i wondered why he has shoulder
blades and hips
if if we're not related to each other
you know
um why do we have the same anatomy uh
it didn't seem to make sense to me uh
so there was all these things that kept
hitting me
just as a kid and i was really
interested in biology
and finally someone in the mormon church
told me oh it it's
evolution's okay and how mormons have
been dealing with it is they've just
been saying let biologists teach biology
and let the church teach
the gospel and it'll get worked out
someday if there's where there's
conflicts it'll get worked out
someday so that was the
the tactic that that mormons were using
at the time that
i think they still are kind of using
that because byu teaches evolution
and they don't the church doesn't try
and step on their toes when they do that
they just let him do it
uh that's one way to deal with it you
have
uh biologos uh
seemed to me early on to be kind of that
way like let's just
let's just have a conversation about
this but
um some people in the biologos group
have have seemed to have gotten very
specific as to how
we should marry science and religion
right
and then um you have well
uh there's lots of different ways that
people have done this
um and i i think that's great
but what i keep finding is so you know
the catholics found a way to get over
this
but the southern baptists don't like to
do what the pope says
so they need their own solution
and the mormons don't follow the pope so
they need their own solution it's like
it's like we haven't been able to find a
a
single solution to put a stop to this
fight
right and that's been kind of
frustrating
do you see any benefits though to this
conflict between
science and religion here well
benefits is a hard word i would say
opportunity is a better
way to put it so i think there's a lot
of opportunities been missed
but if the opportunity was claimed i
think there'd be some really great
benefits
does that make sense yeah i think
science here is really interesting
cool i think that's one of those
opportunities that that is just totally
missed most people care about
ancestry and genetics and but they
haven't really they don't really know
how it all fits to you
right we've been wondering for a long
time about
who we are as humans what is it that
makes us human exactly and how do we
raise
and that conversation has been going on
in science and it's also been going on
in theology and to bring those two
uh discourses into actual real
meaningful dialogue
hey that's a major benefit where there
could be some really
great exchanges that happen where we
really start to understand how nakedness
how um natural i could say in sacred
history combined and i think that that's
that's like the real opportunity i think
also there's an opportunity to put to
end
an immense amount of conflict i think
one of the positive things about the
conflict
is that people have been very clear
theologically about why they reject
evolution
and the constant thing keeps on coming
up is not actually
from the animal kingdom even the earth
creationists believe in evolution
there are people who who put a high
emphasis on
the age of the earth that's actually in
a historical view
that's you know a rough movement in a
lot of ways
um the part where when young earth
creationists and old earth creationists
get together on common ground
the point where they always disagree is
going to be with evolution is going to
be about adam and eve and that's where
people really put the foot down
it turns out that that's just not in
conflict with evolutionary science
you can look at all these statements
that people have made and the good news
is that's just not in conflict and
that's
that's a really exciting thing to
recognize
and to realize that there's actually um
uh
just a larger range of possible views
now than people have been really
pressing
and so there isn't really a reason to
move away from how most denominations
have thought about adam and eve
yeah i i have i actually feel like
some in some points that the conflict
between
the science and religion here has made
evolution more interesting to people
than
like physics for example like there's um
there's this like desire to come get in
a fight so it kind of turns
evolution into not just the science but
also this this boxing arena
which kind of has some interesting
positives there's a
negative like you know culture war
nonsense but i think
man now we're drawn to places where
there's tension like there's an
ideological
tension right or um or tension between
ideas
the part what drew me to science and not
even about evolution just
you know scientists are always like you
know debating
different ideas back and forth i mean
it's normally about arcane stuff that no
one cares about that
but that given tug and that push and
pull of ideas
um you know where we're shaping it by
evidence we're trying to make sense of
it together and we're making sense of a
different way
we're trying to kind of come to some
sort of sentences together is really the
beauty of
science right and um
i think what has happened too often
is i do think it's legitimate to say you
know i'm gonna see some legitimacy in
science and i see some legitimacy in my
religious place but i don't know how
they fit together which is what you're
kind of describing
with mormonism that is a horrible place
to be that's also i think where the
catholic church has been in a lot of
ways too
but at some point um it's really
fun and it's part of the joy of it all
to actually start getting to the details
to try and hash it out
and to really really understand instead
of just
you know hitting snooze on things
forever to actually really understand
and to put things into dialogue with one
another and the way i think
it's made sense is to understand that
a productive way of exchange between you
know two immovable rocks like if you
have like theology on one hand you know
science on the other
are really productive ways and in both
places um
there's a legitimacy to questions
and and it's it's in everyone's interest
to take questions seriously
like it's okay for the scientists to go
to the theologian and say well what
about people outside the garden
that's completely legitimate what
exactly is a scripture against this and
what exactly is a tradition against that
it's a press on that that is legitimate
to do and it's legitimate for the
the theologian or just the you know the
thoughtful person the church to come to
the scientists and say
what actually is the evidence against
our descent from adam
that fact that it is religiously
motivated is not
a reason to dismiss would scientists
care about
good questions and that is a good
question even though it's religiously
motivated it should be engaged with
honesty and rigor
yeah uh jerry coyne calls
your work bogus accommodationism and
i feel like i agree with the science
anywhere yeah yeah
yeah while agreeing with the science and
we're going to go over what what what
that science specifically is here
in a second but i i just want to point
this out to people that
uh there's been a lot of uh you know
from my perspective as someone who's
trying to get through to middle
schoolers and high schoolers that's my
main target audience like
of course i don't want them to come to
school and have to have us ultimatum
between
the religion of their family versus
you know the something that's that's
being taught in their science class i
don't want them to have to have that
that's not i don't feel like that's
appropriate
but um you know jerry coyne he's at uh
he's at a university
and you know as as you and i have talked
about in the past
one-on-one he's he a lot of his
motivation
is to as the promotion of atheism
and and even evangelists right so i
think that that's okay
i think at some point though we have to
make a decision
for ourselves about are we promoting our
personal beliefs or are we trying to
advance science
and if we're trying to advance science i
think uh it's imperative that we make
space for people who believe differently
than us
so and that means that we don't
use science unfairly
as a wedge against other people's
beliefs that's just not right
it it deeply undermines science to do
that
and you know maybe their beliefs are
wrong but you don't make up stuff in
science to tell them
one of one of the things that i've found
in like when i look at arguments
people are having in the comment
sections of my videos about the theory
of evolution
they're arguing about evolution but
they're not really arguing about
evolution arguing about whether or not
god exists
and they're just they're not mentioning
that at all in fact on the stated
clearly channel
i have filters to block i had so much
um proselytizing and um it's for school
use
so i actually have i block religious
words because so
those comments just don't end up showing
up so people but people have these
insane debates on there
and they they end up
i mean they're fighting like really
angrily
with each other and it's definitely not
about the science they're definitely
they're
arguing about god through this like
side channel and it i find that really
interesting that this happens
it's also an issue about justice
too for many people where they feel that
they feel that
if they haven't been hurt and the people
that they care about
have been i don't hear what i said but i
said i think part of it is also about
justice for them i think that
they feel like they haven't been hurt
that that
what they think and their values aren't
important
and so and then i think what really
reinforces that
is a lot of people will then start
thumping on them for their beliefs
and and so that just makes them feel
more unheard and becomes more about
justice
and in the end i actually agree that
that's not the right way to handle those
sorts of concerns i mean i think it's
not about ridiculing those sorts of
beliefs i think we should
because they can't really they don't
have a right to tell scientists what to
think about scientific data
but they certainly have the right to ask
legitimate good faith questions and we
have an obligation
except public funding that are trying to
use science to serve the common good
to hear those questions and receive them
empathetically and answer them with
honesty and rigor
yeah yeah let's let's dive into
the the thesis of your book so
you your claim is that evolution uh
doesn't actually have to be in conflict
with the
literal story of adam and eve so
you're not saying you're not saying that
science somehow
proves adam and eve in any way you're
just saying that it actually
the blow that people seem to think that
evolution makes to the story of adam and
eve doesn't actually
connect uh so if you can
explain that to us here uh the best as
you can your elevator pitch of of what
that
what that means here yeah and it's
important to recognize that this is
simultaneously a pretty radical claim
but it's also very limited
i'm not claiming that the literal
account of genesis is true or that
science demonstrates true i mean maybe
it is
but what i am saying is that there's no
scientific evidence
against it uh and i think that's the
surprising piece
and that's important because a lot of
people have claimed that there was
evidence against it
and what do i mean by literal what i
talk about is um adam and eve in the
fairly recent
past created de novo without parents
as a special act of god and ancestors of
everyone
that's that's basically uh in a nutshell
how most people through history have
understood the genesis account of course
there's other ways of reading it
but most people have understood it and
there's been a lot of
people have said that that's actually
important for several reasons in
theology to them
the times are willing to give up on one
or two pieces of it so for example
catholics have given up
or been willing to give up on de novo
creation have been willing to give up
on on on having them recent they're okay
with them being in the far distant past
that's one way to resolve it right um
other people
um i've become okay with uh just giving
up on them being ancestors of assault
giving up on what's called the doctrine
of monogenesis
and uh that that's another way to
resolve it but there ends up being
uh that ends up being a fairly large
revision of theology for
many uh for many christians and so they
have just
been stuck in thesis or limbo trying to
make sense of it
even when they want to take a
non-oppositional view to evolutionary
science
that ends up being the sticking point
the can you explain to us this this
difference between
uh genealogical ancestry versus genetic
ancestry
yeah so it gets the idea of like it
sounds like it's in conflict so why
isn't it right
and so there's two issues one is that we
have to really
understand first of all the distinction
that there is a difference between
something called genealogical ancestry
which is the normal way think about
ancestry
genetic ancestry and i'll explain that
in a moment then the second issue which
i think is just as important as we have
to understand that human
is a very important word to us but
it is not actually defined
scientifically in a meaningful way
and there's a difference between how
scientists use that word and how
theologians do and
when you kind of recognize if that's a
word that's multivalent that has
many legitimate meanings then uh
then you can kind of give autonomy to
different people to use a term in
different ways and that really dissolves
an immense amount of conflict
so let's talk about the first word of
ancestry first does that make sense or
is that where you want to start
yeah genetic ancestry is not
genealogical was that a surprise to you
when you wrote it john
well no uh the the one thing that did
so yeah i mean i've been teaching
genetics for a while
but and and evolution but i'm always
thinking about it
in a very um usually when i'm thinking
about genetics i'm thinking about it at
a generation to generation line like how
is it that meiosis works and
how do things get spread from one
generation to the next
and and then you know we'll use genetic
evidence to to show common ancestry
between different species and figure out
who's
more closely related to whom and i
i guess i'd never really stop to think
about uh
how how that
well just just that
when you're moving forward in time the
number of offspring that you have
increases exponentially so the number of
descendants that you have increases
exponentially
but when you're looking backwards in
time your number of ancestors increases
exponentially
um but obviously the the genetics being
shared
does not increase exponentially so
most of my most of my ancestors when i'm
doing my genealogy
and mormons do genealogy i know a lot of
my genealogy because i was raised mormon
and uh and i did think about this when i
was a kid
like i was like can't isn't pretty much
everyone
my ancestor isn't anyone's
accomplishment my ancestor but which
ones actually matter
um so i guess i had been thinking about
this even since i was pretty young about
the
the fact that you know all these people
in my family history
like did i really inherit anything from
that person i don't think so
maybe um as far as genes go
but i never i never thought i never sat
and thought about it real deep
uh in until like hearing your argument
but
yeah so let's break this down for
listeners it turns out that
um genetic ancestry is how most
scientists
think about initially when you talk
about ancestry if you start asking
questions about ancestry genetics
they'll
they'll go straight to genetics right
what is genetic ancestry it's like a
it means that there's pieces of dna that
dna that share a templating history that
go back
directly to someone else right
and it's really not about individuals
it's about those structures of the dna
so when we talk about ancestry we're
talking about dna
when we have genetics right that's not
what most people think about
yeah it's certainly not how the biblical
authors were because they didn't know
anything about dna
right um so we have most people think
about ancestry
is um using the mental model of like you
know written down genealogies right
which is this idea there's like a
um a chain of reproductive dissent it's
about organisms or people
about parents and grandparents and great
grandparents and their offspring and
their offspring's offspring
it's an ordinary way of understanding uh
ancestry which is very different than
the scientific
genetic way of understanding ancestry
another thing about the behavioral gap
so if you care about genetics
we can talk about one mitochondrial for
example mitochondrial eve exists
and so to be clear that's not talking
about the ancestry of all people per se
that's its category
it's talking about the ancestry of
mitochondria the mitochondrial
chromosome
and the last common ancestor for that uh
was probably you know
um over a hundred thousand years ago
there's debate about the exact time it
was over a hundred thousand years ago
and some people said well that that
actually rules out a recent adam and eve
because that's where genealogical i mean
that's where the genetic ancestry
is most recently converged that just
turns out to be false
yeah well y chromosome what what people
are actually saying when they say
mitochondrial eve they're saying that
mitochondria was fixed the the mutations
found in mitochondria were fixed
in our species at this time in history
uh well they weren't fixed then right so
that's just more kind of when they pull
left
all right okay yeah right right right
like full lust at that point
and so that an idea i mean that's just
basically
what people said okay that kind of puts
a limit on one adam and eve and
that's that's just not true because uh
for a long time
people have wondered about people
outside the garden and maybe we got our
mitochondria from outside the garden and
we don't actually have yeast you know
in us right now another um example would
be
y chromosome atom uh people once again
over a hundred thousand years ago let's
talk about genetic ancestry
uh that's very different than what
scripture's talking about if it's
talking about anything real if it's
talking about anything real i mean
most it can be talking about is physical
descent
and that just works very different so a
good way to think about this is just
about
yourself and your parents like all of us
have parents right and i have a mom and
dad you do too
and i get fifty percent of my dna about
fifty percent
from my mom and not fifty percent from
my dad it's a little less for my dad
and uh that means that my mom is only
50 my genetic ancestor
and my dad is only 50 percent my
ancestors now go back one more
generation
and we're dealing with grandparents
right and uh
i get 25 of my dna about for each of my
grandparents
yeah with recombination all that there's
also a little bit of noise that goes
into this right
and uh and that's great
and all but you know uh that means only
25 percent of my genetic ancestors
but they're 100 of my genealogical
ancestors
i mean i descended from all of them
right are they you know it kind of goes
from like a binary
are they there or not to not now what's
surprising if we start doing this and
counting back i only know
maybe about four generations back in my
lineage you're mormon so you probably
you were mormon so you can go probably a
little bit farther back right maybe six
or seven or eight generations
yeah well one of my
one of my lineages goes back to uh
[Music]
in uh england that links back to royalty
which
they would fake their genealogies all
the way back to adam
yeah a little bit of other issues too
but it's fake yeah well the other two of
that is like how many
can you tell me in those genealogies
that are written down how many times
there was an adoption or infidelity
no no no no yeah it's all it's all just
public records
and public records so i mean it's a good
mental model but it ends up really
falling apart on these things so if you
do that though but if you go back to
actually what the actual chain battle
descent was
you go back to like about 10 to 15
generations that's just about
300 years or so about the vast majority
of your uh ancestors didn't actually
give you any dna
which is a really crazy idea and so we
call them sometimes as genetic ghosts
that they're that they're actually real
answers so they didn't give you any dna
and that's not like some sort of weird
unlikely thing
um it's just that's what the majority
cases so the really
surprising thing um is
the lottery winners are the one the
people that actually ends up giving us
dna
the vast majority of dna out there gets
lost
what that means is um if you do this and
you kind of trace this it turns out that
um
that adam and eve if they existed they
could have been as recent as
6 000 years ago in the middle east and
they would have become ancestors of
everyone
um across the entire globe by uh
by uh one a.d like before jesus you know
jesus
ascension and without feeling
you know uh when when like the doctor
gets formed that we all
we all descend from adam you know maybe
it's true maybe we all really do it's
just been from adam and eve
there's no evidence against that in fact
there's a lot of evidence yes
that that's actually the most uh
plausible reading of the data now
there's a couple
there's a couple minor technical
questions that come up about isolated
populations
but uh but they're not nearly as as
definitive as people
have thought too when you actually look
at them there's been a lot of evidence
genetically
and we can't see now the majority of
you know movement between populations in
the past we can't see
but the fact matter is in almost every
population we look at we see
a ton of evidence of movement and across
the globe and
in really large movements and it turns
out the idea of isolated populations
is um is essentially you know in the
vast majority of cases the mythology the
one place
where there is a possibility of isolated
population
in the very recent time frame meaning
just uh you know over the last eight
thousand years
is uh tasmania but
you were not disputed and debatable
but every other case like the andaman
islands um or
or the americas or you know amazonian
jungle
or you know those lost tribes in africa
they're all connected to us they weren't
distinct from us we're all connected
together in a common family
yeah let me let me try and stop and
summarize things
and um we can see if
i'm understanding everything correctly i
just want to summarize things for the
audience too
i'm getting a lot of comments here i
want everyone in the audience i want to
know that we're going to do
questions later on and if you have a
question
if you do at stated space
casually i'll make sure to see it it'll
highlight orange in the comments for me
so anyone who's watching this live right
now
you can start submitting questions and
we'll try and get to those
uh at the end here for those who have
been watching this channel for a while
you know that when i'm doing live stuff
i'm actually really bad at keeping
on top of the comments but uh yeah if
you
at stated casually me i will i will see
those
in the in the comments here so feel free
to ask some questions
but just to summarize what it is that
uh that you're kind of your big
the the big statement that you're making
is that look uh
christians want to believe that aveniff
lived what six to ten thousand years ago
right
around there's a range of christian
views but most christians through
history have really understood adame as
de novo created in the recent past
ancestors of us all
right i could be consistent with
evolution
it and for a long time people have said
well the theory of evolution proves that
it wasn't
recent because you couldn't possibly
have i mean
genetically we're related to other apes
so
obviously we weren't just created de
novo
what you're saying is that well in the
story that we find in the bible
you have people outside the garden that
adam and eve's descendants go mate with
it's pretty obvious that that's
happening it's it's said multiple times
right
and that's not because of evolution i'm
saying i mean you can see that in church
history as something people are
talking about yeah for hundreds of years
i mean even going back you know into
like early jewish thought on this
this is not like some sort of crazy
revision this has just been part of the
theological conversation for a while so
so what you're pointing out is like like
look people
the bible already has an open window for
this
to be okay where you could actually have
people that had been evolving outside
the garden and a special creation inside
the garden
so what's the conflict is basically what
you've been saying
and the scientific community might say
oh well six thousand years is
isn't long enough for someone to be the
ancestor for for any couple to
to be the ancestor of all humans
and what you're saying is well from a
genealogical perspective that's actually
possible
if um there's been enough mixing of
populations
so i guess the one thing that would that
would that scientifically would say no
there's no way is if we actually had a
group of humans
that were completely reproductively
isolated for
over ten thousand years or so then you
would have a problem
but well it would it may be a very minor
problem it would just mean that you'd
push adam and eve a little bit farther
back
yeah and so and there's already reasons
why people might want to push out and
move a little bit farther back
uh you know like maybe 15 000 years ago
or 12 000 years ago
in that range there just isn't any
conflict at all yeah so
um you know well the magic
the boundary case but that's not really
conflict with science maybe we can say
it's debatable but um
but you know recent adam and eve is just
not an issue
yeah the so one thing i also want to
make really clear is that you're not
saying that this is a scientific theory
that that's you're not trying to
scientifically say that adam and eve
existed that's not what you're trying to
say you're trying to say that
the science of evolution doesn't
necessarily conflict with
what's being taught in the bible science
doesn't tell us that adam and eve exists
any more than it tells us that you know
pilot existed yeah even though he
probably did i don't know of any
historians like secular or non that
doubt that pontius pilas was a real
person you don't get that from genetics
it's outside of the purview
you can't you know genetics doesn't come
tagged with the names of people
connected to it and how they fit into
you know the historical record it just
doesn't do that yeah
and um it's just
the important question i think that
rises in theology is how to make sense
of people outside the garden
yeah i'm not gonna think about the
conversation to be had uh one way how
it gets misunderstood is just thinking
that this is connected to polygenesis
which are you know theories of origins
that
um eventually connected to racism but a
key component of all those theories of
polygenesis
was that people alive today
had different origins not that we're
connected it was denying the unity of
mankind
but that's exactly the opposite of what
this is it's actually saying that we all
descend from adam
not that we had separate origins and so
black people came
from those of all people and then maybe
white people came from adam and eve
that's not what it's saying it's
literally teaching that that's
impossible
that doesn't make any sense um
scientifically
and so we have a ton of positive
scientific evidence because there's been
intermixing
on an ongoing basis uh you know in the
in the recent half and
go back into the ancient past but
it ends up being i would say dialogue i
wouldn't say adam name are a scientific
theory but what i'm talking about is
definitely in close conversation with
real scientific theories
does that make any sense to you i mean
you you listen to a lot of the books you
got
you probably get what i'm saying right
yeah okay so yeah the one thing in your
book
that that made me uncomfortable was
you're you consistently call it a
hypothesis
that um that adam and eve are related to
all of us
which i mean that's fine except for that
i feel like uh
people could get confused that you're
saying that it's a scientific hypothesis
which i mean i think i think that what
you're saying is that it's a theological
hypothesis
am i correct in that well i think
there's parts of it that are scientific
and there's parts that are theological
right
so um so for me that the main thing that
differentiate differentiates a
scientific hypothesis versus
like you know a non-scientific
hypothesis is that in science we care
about
like all the claims that we make need to
be based on things that are
are observable and testable what you're
saying is that
if if you give
the bible if you are a person who
believes that the bible is a source of
truth
then you can actually also base some of
your hypothesis on what's in the bible
uh which is well that that's not what
i'm saying i'm saying it's like a
thought experiment look no one thinks
that maxwell's demon
is a real thing right right
but we can still kind of take it as a
thought experiment and work forward and
try to make sense of it and then
something really valuable to science i
think adam and eve
are useful as a thought experiment okay
yeah
yeah yeah i i i would agree with that
that they are useful as a thought
experiment
and of course there's a long tradition
of people using um
biblical terms in science too like well
mitochondrial
eve for example and so all a hypothesis
is is to actually say to be very clear
what you're saying
is your starting model and able to see
if there's any evidence you try and
falsify it you're trying to see if
there's any evidence that falsifies
right yeah that's all i'm saying um and
i'm very clear too that the idea of a de
novo creation of adam and eve isn't
really a proper scientific
they say that directly right right yeah
you do state that
right up front um that what one of the
things that that jerry coyne
says has said um
he says as for me i continue to adhere
to hitchens razor what can be asserted
without evidence can also be dismissed
without evidence
and i from reading your book i would say
that you're
you're totally fine with that like
you're not expecting scientists to now
go
say oh adam and eve were a thing you're
expecting them to continue
using hitchens razor or well no
i would say that he has really missed
the point first of all he didn't read
the book which is fine he just read an
article i think he got uh he got like
peppered with a lot of questions and
didn't know how to and wanted to kind of
make a statement and how he'd be
look i think that um that there are
there are purely scientific questions
that are connected to this that have
nothing to do with anime
we can ask how likely is it that a
person
living in the middle east or any other
part of the world
we could just pick a place like in you
know end up being answers is
everyone alive today and people have
actually published
that's a purely scientific question um
there's
nothing there right now when it comes to
stuff that's
outside of science the fact of the
matter is that we all believe things
outside of science
there's no people out there that will
tell me
john that you used to be a mormon
i mean it's not in the peer review
published literature as far as i know
is it i mean no no you believe it
um i don't see any reason not to take
your word for it
i mean there's a lot of things that seem
to be pretty consistent about you saying
that
uh you know maybe you're lying to me
that's not true
i think it's probably true that that was
a reality about the past that you're
telling me
and it's not a scientific literature
it's not science but it's
true i think there's just a lot of
things in this world that are not
science that are also true that we
all even like the most devout you know
science thumping atheists out there is
going to accept is true
yeah well you know when i think about
what is science
this is obviously something that could
be debated about for you know
for hours but or for years actually
but the the the phrase nullius and verba
is something that's really
helped helped me clarify what is
what is science and what's not so that
means that means take no one's word for
it and that was the
that was the slogan of the the royal
society or the royal institution
uh the uh one of the earliest one of the
oldest
um still-standing scientific
organizations so they say take no one's
word for it
and if you look at older writings by
people members of the society
they would actually include the bible as
a legitimate form of
evidence for stuff they were
most of the scientists at the time were
also you know they were like religious
yeah that's not how science works today
we don't use scripture as evidence but
um this is the part where
i think uh where i think jerry coyne is
missing something there are people who
think
i mean i wouldn't even stand one
independent of science for seeing
legitimacy in scripture
and so saying that because something i
believe
of because of scripture is not true just
because science didn't tell us that it's
kind of absurd
um i mean that that sort of razor would
apply to just about
almost all i mean all human knowledge
could be deleted
with that razor that's just that's just
crazy well yeah
well the the thing that
the thing that that we have in science
is that it if you're going to make a
statement
it needs to be backed up with things
that we can observe so we can observe
how evolution works today
and then project that into the past we
can observe the fossil record
and piece together things and if you're
going outside of that if you're going
out
if you're if you're basing things on uh
you know some people say that
god shouldn't ever try to be studied in
science i would say that if god made
himself observable then scientists could
immediately start studying him and there
would be no issue because
what we care about is you know basing
our conclusions on observation
when you say take no one's word for it
as like the the main
logo or the the motto for science what
you're saying is that i can't just take
someone's word for it that god exists we
need
we need we need it to be demonstrated
well it all comes down to
how you do that like if if to take that
as a very literal statement would
actually mean that there's actually no
point in publishing a paper because no
one should take your word for it
well we shouldn't even go to we should
even go to go to pubmed or anything like
that because we shouldn't take for worse
people we're gonna go find ourselves i
mean
that's not actually how it applies the
fact of the matter is that scientists
generally take the words of other
scientists as legitimate
it's like truthful reports of what
they've seen
we have like a employed policing
ourselves over that and we have a high
standard on honesty but the fact that i
was a vast majority of science
that you teach or that we do or we learn
and we know we got
because someone told us we didn't get it
from after doing this
oh right well yeah i understand that but
the way that they structured their their
papers which is actually the way that we
still structure them now
is that you you have the evidence you
present that evidence and then you
present
what you think that evidence means so
you're presenting observations
of course someone's trusting that you
actually saw what you saw
and a lot of times you have to prove it
by actually showing images in your paper
or whatever
but a lot of times other times you don't
but you do have to be able to provide
enough information that someone can
replicate your experiment
if they so choose so we do have this
this deep distrust and taking each
other's word in science
but in practice it it's pretty rare for
someone to actually
understand that you're not it's not
enough to give your conclusions in
science you have to show your work
right right you have to actually show
how your conclusion follows from the
evidence
what people are going to trust when you
prevent evidence
in general i mean unless you really
ruined your reputation
right right right dishonesty and fraud
in science it happens
um and it's and the reason why it's such
a big deal is because we want to be able
to trust people
right we police ourselves on that really
tightly but
uh but you're right i mean you have to
actually show how what you're doing
actually comes from that but
been really clear about that no one
started looking only at the scientific
evidence
we're going to conclude that adam and
eve the biblical story is true
that's not what you would ever expect to
get it's like what you would get instead
would be
um would be the question of like well
okay so there's a story out there
that might have legitimacy where you
have to consider suffering
because science doesn't really have any
good tools for assessing that
but if that's but there is the part of
um
you know whether or not that story
matches what we're seeing in genetics or
even conflict with it
or is it is it confirmed conflicted or
consistent
i think what you see is that it's just
consistent um it's not
there isn't the conflict that people
have really argued and
and to answer the question honestly then
it doesn't matter if you're a christian
or not
it's someone else is there evidence
against the denobo creation of adam and
eve in the early recent past
the right answer it's actually you know
objective answer
is actually there is no conflict it's
not a conflict of evidence the key
question is whether or not there were
people outside the garden
because if there weren't maybe there
would be a conflict again likely not me
there is a conflict if there were no
people outside the garden if you were
reading so so so what you're saying is
that
um yeah that
science doesn't make the blow it does
the punch doesn't connect
between science and adam and
eve if you consider that the people
outside the garden were evolving
the way that science yeah has understood
evolution interesting theological
questions so this is where there's an
opportunity for the conversation that
scientists
sit back do our job as scientists of
just being truthful and honest about
what the evidence does
and does not show right and
then bring a legitimate interesting
question back to the theologians to kind
of work
and that's like the exchange you know
like good conversations are um
you know kind of like that back and
forth of
you know you say something john
you asked me a question and then um you
know i
i say something and um if it wasn't like
an interview maybe i'd be asking you
questions more too
right right right speaking of questions
we actually we got one that i think
should probably be addressed
um now rather than when we actually do
main questions and we got
a question here wait adam and eve are a
thought experiment
so basically you said earlier that adam
and eve or thought experiment
i think that what people are thinking is
okay so you don't actually you don't
personally believe in adam and eve you
think they're just a thought experiment
so if you could just clarify that here
yeah so my book is really neutral in
this regard it's written so that
christians that really
think that adam and eve are real and
that um that genesis
is real history and it should be trusted
over science can pick it up and read it
and think that
evolution is the thought experiment
they're going to be working through
right
it's also written so atheists can pick
it up people like nathan lance or or you
john
and others can pick it up and read it um
we're even very point and say okay so
there's a way i can think about how to
name as like a legitimate entity as a
maxwell's demon in this right and so
it's really speaking to those groups
now what do i think about this well i
mean i'm a christian i'm from the
lasagna covenant
i'm also a scientist and i'm from
evolutionary science like now the
science i'm putting in here
is uh i mean it's definitely been
conflict with what for example biologos
has really put forward for a long time
and other scientists but it's not a
concept of science a lot of
non-christian scientists ended up
endorsing the book because of that
and so um i didn't i didn't actually
make this book about my personal beliefs
i'm gonna
acknowledge them in the beginning but
when it comes to adam and eve i i just
haven't said anything
about my life because it's really
irrelevant the argument i made is really
about
about really hearing um
you know really receiving good questions
arising in the religious community with
empathy
and and and answering them with honesty
and rigor
and that's something that all of us
should do on letter sentences whether
we're krishna
and whether or not we think adam and eve
are real or not that's what we should do
and that's what this book is trying to
do and then of course it
brings up really interesting theological
questions and i gotta tell you i've been
having fun watching atheists get into
theological debates and having fun with
this too
exploring not because i'm necessarily
convinced it's all true but because um
they can still pick up the thought
experiment and explore
you know what the meaning of original
sin could be or the meaning of the image
of god and all those sorts of things
and explore that you don't actually have
to believe it's true to play that game
and enjoy the conversation now
those conversations do shape us and then
maybe they do change our beliefs and
but we can still have them without
really necessarily knowing where it's
going to go
right yeah i so i
feel like in your book maybe you didn't
actually say it explicitly but i feel
like in your book
you you do say that you believe
in a recent creation of adam and eve
is that something you don't want to come
out and say too strongly either way are
you trying to stay neutral
right down to it i can see a lot of ways
to make sense of the theology
and scripture together um
there's so many ways that
i see that i'm having fun with the
creativity of playing with it all and i
don't really see a reason to kind of
land down on
i can see legitimacy to that you know a
lot of the work i've done has ended up
being really valuable for example to win
lane craig
and reasons to believe so these are uh
um
pretty important leaders that are
christian
that had really been crowded out by
evolutionary creationists
um really with incorrect explanations of
science
and as i've really understood the
science matter you know reasons to
believe is becoming
to a far more friendly biology friendly
uh point of view and so it says william
lane
too and even though they they put out of
me far more ancient
and ultimately i think that's good for
science and that's really
uh really what i'm trying to do here
more than promote any particular
um you know detail of this i just want
to get the answer
yeah i feel like i feel like you you not
coming hard on a solid position
is a real benefit because
honestly i think that your
realization here that okay science
doesn't actually have to
the blow isn't the blow that we think
that science has made hasn't
it hasn't actually made a connection it
hasn't actually hit
if you look really closely at the bible
and look really closely at
at uh at what science is telling a very
literal reading of genesis and in
conflict so then of course less little
readings
right right um i feel like this is
honestly i think that 50 years from now
maybe 100 years from now
this will be just normal
doctrine and mormonism in
the southern baptist convention and
catholicism
maybe even in islam i don't know i don't
i don't understand islam well enough but
i feel like that should be interesting
so yeah what
sorry i say that again well there's a
really interesting um article that came
out
referencing my work on islam actually
it's okay
so you might be right or within the
jewish community i don't know
i don't understand how the jewish
community has dealt with evolution in
the past
it seems like everyone who i know who is
a practicing jew doesn't have a problem
with
um with evolution but i don't know
how diverse that i don't i don't know if
there are young earth creationists
within judaism but the
or sorry i should say anti-evolution
creationists
um i th that's another interesting thing
you're bringing up labels here like
theistic evolution
which i guess is is what biologos
talks about a lot
you have intelligent design uh
and i feel like all of these labels have
tons of baggage
right because there have been injuries
and conflicts and fighting
for so long um do you feel like you need
to
re-name what it is that you're saying or
do you call yourself a young earth
creationist or what
well i'm not well i do think that
there's a real value in
in thinking through language carefully
and in labels
so um
i think it really helps navigate
sticky conflicts with individuals um
so for example i don't i i say early on
in the book that i'm not an evolutionary
creationist
the reason why is i think that um you
know biologos is a great organization
that's done a lot of good in the world
and i think it's great that you know
when you mention them briefly that that
is helpful to people honestly
just the fact that you're acknowledging
those beliefs alone
would do that type of diffusing rather
than i mean
it's not specific about their name but i
think it's great that when you mention
them that's the case
the fact of the matter that people have
been following the conversation you know
they brought forward a very specific
case and um
and they and you know that that that
ended up not really
uh being really true to the science and
it burned some bridges
and so i think it's turning
out now that biologos is consistent with
science
but they are just a narrow range and i
think that that's okay
they're allowed to have a door in like a
narrow range it's just there's a larger
larger group of people outside there
that that um
that are going to be okay with
evolutionary science but they're going
to disagree with biologos on theology
and so i think having some terms to
describe that be helpful so what i do
say is that i'm a christian that affirms
the science of evolution or
the christian
yeah and there's been also discussion
about other terms that people have used
so some people throw out the idea of
martha evolution i don't really like
that one but um
so that's one the other one too that i
think is really interesting
is if you look at your creationism uh
they have a range of views and they're
in their camp as well there's actually
something called young life creationism
have you ever heard of that
before no they believe that the earth is
old and our universe is old
uh but life on earth arose just six
thousand years ago
and they believe in like in the global
flood and all that so and
that's actually um that was actually
more common
than young earth creationism as you had
what the aig creationism 150 years ago
so um seventh-day adventists tend to be
um young biosphere creationists oh
really uh yeah
because from my understanding of the
history here i thought that seventh-day
adventists were kind of like the origin
of young earth creationism well they are
that's the thing the origin of
creationism was more young life
creationism uh interesting
part they have in common is flood
geology so it's really oriented around
florida but
putting that aside for a second um when
you look at what
how they think about scripture they
think that there's a scoping involved in
certain points and so when you really
think about the genealogical it gives an
opportunity for a young adam creation
view
which could potentially fit um from a
theological and a hermeneutical point of
view fairly close
to young earth creationism even though
it allows revolution in an old earth
in the same way that young biosphere
creation allows for an old earth but
this just
extends it to allow for human evolution
and
um what i've seen which is really
encouraging is i mean i deal with
homeschool kids a lot and i deal with
their parents
and i also deal with faculty at young
creation at schools
yeah quite often um there is the whole
injured um
angry response but quite often i will
get responses of people just feeling
like something relief
like oh that's what evolution could be i
don't have a problem with it
yeah and that that relief
that relief is so desperately needed
that because like i said when i was a
kid i felt this
tension and it was insane i felt like i
was
gonna go get attacked at school so the
what i would like to see is see
if there's a place for young earth
creationists to start accepting as a
possibility even that's not their
personal view
so you can kind of think about
institutions um like you know
like colleges and things like that just
say hey you know young adam creation
isn't what we personally believe we also
have a problem with it maybe we would
hire faculty like that
maybe we would um maybe we would
you know point your kids into that
direction if we're going to accept
evolution even though we were rejected
you know
yeah that would be a better world that
would be a better world for faith
um it would be a bit more free or it'd
be more true to scripture
and it would also be more true to the
science um i think that's
that's possible i mean we're starting to
see that actually with the old earth
krishna so you talked about the baptist
congregation they're actually inviting
me as a visiting scholar to one of their
seminaries this next year
the southern baptist convention yeah um
and so it's not the eastern uh baptist
theological seminary it has happened to
me there as uh
something there's a building scholar in
a large part because of this work
i've been you know having uh
conversations with with you know phd
students there their writing thesis is
related to this and all that it's really
interesting to see that play out
um and
it's just it's just a big opportunity
for them to come and kind of work out
what they think is going to be the way
that they want to come to terms with
evolution
in a way that's true to what they think
is important rather than
really uh adopting the narrative that
the way for them to accept evolution is
to change who they are and change their
beliefs and become something else
so um and so why shouldn't we support
that a scientist well i think it's it's
kind of a no-brainer of course we should
support that yeah
i'm getting some clarification questions
here that i think
again i mean i think we just need to
keep on
re-saying this in different ways so
people can make sure that they're
they're getting what your position is
so we've got one question as far as i am
aware
swamidas position is that we share
ancestry with our primate cousins like
chimpanzees etc
but that the evidence allows the
possibility that a human couple
was de novo created so could you just uh
i was just calling the swamidas position
this is just one thought experiment
there's lots of other thought
experiments i play with and what do we
do when we started
when we started enumerating them one two
three this
book really is exploring the idea yeah
of that
experiment so yeah that's the thought
experiment that yeah
that the people outside the garden god
created through a providentially
governed process
of common descent
it's natural but god could have been
moving to points science can't really
tell one way or another and that's fine
whatever
maybe god endows a human soul at some
point or maybe there's particular
mutations that he inspires or maybe he
does it pre-coded into the universe and
it's like all just by
you know providentially you know god it
says the scripture god governs the the
cast of lots or the cast of a die is
what they say
if god's providence isn't threatened by
us you know willing to die
i'm pretty sure it's not threatened by
uh you know random mutation
and and god's god's in control that he
governs that process and he makes those
people that way
but then for um for uh reasons
associated with um
with when it talks about in scripture
like establishing a covenant with you
and adding
building coming into a relationship with
them he creates a special
couple uh that uh that what we call
maybe sacred humanity
or or covenantal humanity and and they
end up becoming ancestors november and
that's always a relationship
that's um that's what the basic idea is
and of course some of the theology there
um
gets explored in the later part of some
of the book and that's fun to explore
too
but i wouldn't uh honestly say that
that's the position i've landed on
i would say that i would definitely
think that whatever you think about that
it's not inconsistent with evidence and
we need to be clear to people about that
because it's going to be helpful isn't
it
yeah so so the the biggest thrust that
you're just trying to say is
it's not that you're trying to prove
that adam and eve you're not trying to
scientifically prove that adam and eve
existed you're just pointing out that
the science doesn't tell us either way
right exactly
okay and for some reason this is the
hard thing for such a complicated deep
book right i mean
i mean i don't mean that necessarily
deep in a good way it's just that
there's a lot of different
facets to it um right but that is like
at the core
scientific point is just that it's
possible but beyond that i think that
there's a fun conversation to be had i
mean scientists all the time we're
engaging
these larger questions of society and
out there
um there's a fun conversation to be had
i mean like let's have that conversation
too right i mean
i think i think one of the things that
has also uh struck me about the origins
conversation
you talk about injuries right yeah yeah
uh that's there
um i think there's a lot of false
conflict
one uh other thing that really struck me
as i started to study this more
is how race looms race and racism just
looms over the conversation but because
it's controlled primarily
by pardon largely white people
from uh like a dominant you know
american point of view
were not really good at talking about
race it just ends up becoming this
looming thing which gets i mean people
just will race
against their ideological opponents all
the time you can see that both sides
like people who are younger creationists
or creationists will call
evolution inherently racist
scientists call creation inherently
racist too
i heard someone i i've had people blame
darwin for
slavery like do you not understand the
timeline of things
and i think it's really broken i mean i
even was accused of racism
early on but in this stuff i mean the
reason why my logo
you know rejected rejected it was
because of racism that was our stated
reason initially
well i want to talk specifically about
the
the what what racism has to say with
what people said it against your your
line of thinking
related to racism in a second here but
first i just want to talk about
the the conflicts um
like what questions hesitations
have has the secular world come up with
against
what you're saying like what are their
concerns and then i want to talk about
what the
the theological concerns are and then
then we'll focus it on on racism as as
one that's come up i think on both sides
for you right
well i mean yeah what's that
what i found is so i mean i'm a
scientist i'm a secular scientist i'm at
washington university in saint louis
i put this forward initially um in 2017
before i had tenure and my colleagues
who gave me tenure
one thing i'll say is that i mean i'm
not actually aware of any
objections
um like my book was endorsed by
alan templeton who's a leading
population geneticist it was endorsed by
nathan lance
um gary coyne actually agreed with the
science
one branch from the national center uh
for science education then
um ncsc or ncsc i always get the the
initial swap sorry glenn
yeah they um uh
they you know they they were they
understood
you know ken miller uh who's the
chairman of their board um
yeah you know gave a response to it that
you can see online
uh aar it it's non-controversial
actually yeah you're talking about
eugenie scott's i guess she's not
running anymore but yeah yeah
one branch is one who runs it who yeah i
mean
it's just it's just non-controversial
scientifically um
it was bad science that was out there
before this corrects it people have
looked at it who have
qualifications um
they you know they they don't disagree
with it
what they'll do is they'll switch over
if they're going to be critical and just
say it's not important
but that's just a patently absurd
statement the fact of the matter
is that all even if you personally don't
think it's important
it is objectively observably true that
it's important to a lot of other people
in society
right right especially especially a lot
of people in america
so so you know this isn't about whether
or not you like
you know chocolate ice cream or vanilla
ice cream this is rather about whether
you're going to
talk if you're going to stock chocolate
ice cream in the store
that's the question and the fact of the
matter is that there's enough people
like chocolate ice cream that's kind of
a mistake if you don't
include it even if you're personally
hated
and so um so it clearly is important
and i think that's really um that's like
the crux of the argument but i think
once again i think most scientists who
um
are not invested in the culture wars and
that care about advancing science more
than they care about advancing some
ideology whether it be
you know atheism or evolutionary
creation or what have you
most of them um see the potential and
they've been really excited about it
i mean i get i get emails from
scientists all the time talking about
how they shared it with their students
in an appropriate context to be clear um
this isn't like a high school this is
like you know
so forth but it ends up being extremely
helpful for them
so well let's talk about that real
quickly the the
public schools because the the big
conflict that happens
i think like people like jerry coyne
people who have been in this
fight for a long time they
there's this long history of christians
trying to get christian theology taught
as science and in the classroom
and i think a lot of people who are
pushing overly hard and it seems absurd
to you might be it's because they're
like uh this guy
got some trick up a sleeve to try and
get adam and eve taught in school
um in public schools is is this where
this is going because that's what
was happening with the intelligent
design community there was this there
was this
underlying plan yeah it's just an
autoimmune reaction
when that happens i mean part of it i
think a lot of a lot of atheists that
are in the conversation
we're not just atheists it's not just
it's not fair
a lot of people that are pro-evolution
that are in this debate on an ongoing
basis especially in social media i think
um what i observe is that some of them
not all of them
i think they get they got um they got
some joy
out of like you know thumping on
creationists
for you know promoting stupid stuff
you know it makes you feel good it can
right
and a lot of stuff i'm saying sounds
like it's creationists right
and so they just kind of go into that
natural response and
the problem is that we're actually
putting forward good science it's not
creationism writ large it is just
actually
you know making space revolutionary
science and creationist context
and so uh you know i've seen a lot of
people come around on that
when they start looking more closely uh
some of the people who have been the
most part
uh have to come back and apologize yeah
you know after a couple months i mean
another thing too i think some people
early on were really wondering if i was
going to take it too far
yeah if i was going to go from like that
very reasonable position and then if
they kind of gave anything that kind of
hinted that they supported me but i
would go start to say things that were
really absurd
and but i you know i'm like it happened
right don't do that and so i think that
that really started to make it clear
you know like i said now at this point
we have like a national center for
science education i mean glenn grant
published a very positive review of the
book early on
also ken miller too there's a point now
you know it's kind of part of the
establishment
really being legitimate i mean i i mean
i'm part of the panda sun group too
these are groups that have really
defended the instruction of evolution
now that being said i don't think we
should teach religious
views in in
in secular high schools there are a lot
at least so i would agree with that in
in science classroom obviously
if you've got a class on religion and
and theology then obviously you're going
to be teaching
religion and theology but right in in
biology i
yeah i think it's an issue we have a
right to protect our kids from that
if we're not religious right and i mean
i'm religious
like i can choose to put my kids in a
christian school or put them into a
public school and then take them to
you know to a church where they can
learn that stuff or i can teach it to
themselves there's no reason for me to
have to force that teaching on other
people now
that being said there is some really
large secular components to this that
are really important that i would like
to see being talked more
specifically to talk about the genetics
of race would be very important to be
teaching more i think
yeah how interconnected we are and i
think it is actually a very fundamental
thing
in biology to understand the difference
between genetics and genealogy
and i think you know we talk about
mitochondrial eve and why chromosomes
and in high school context there's no
reason not to be talking about recent
genealogical ancestry as well
so i think that that's that's all pure
science right
um yeah i think that would be valuable
of course i do think that there's also
religious context where you could
explain those things and actually make
some connections deeper but i wouldn't
want that to happen in public schools
yeah is there a so
in your book you really drive home the
difference between genealogical ancestry
versus genetic ancestry
does this have anything to do should
this
change at all the way that people are
thinking about common ancestry between
species like between
humans and chimps or between you know
uh roses and bananas
like does does that affect anything
um yeah i think it does i think that
there's a lot of um
precision in our thinking yeah where we
kind of blur these two concepts together
so for example
um it's interesting to look at science
reporting for example on neanderthal
accessory
humans
some of the reports are really good
actually either by accident or
because the person's careful they don't
say things that aren't true but if you
look at it carefully as being said out
there
sometimes you'll you'll hear things like
you know uh
it'll extend beyond the genetic
observation that for example europeans
have a lot of neanderthal unity
but africans don't because then say
that you know africans don't actually
descend from neanderthals but
europeans do that is a comment you might
hear
that's actually not true because it
turns out that we all hear
the exact same common ancestors if you
go that far back that's uncontroversial
i mean so we all descend from
neanderthals
um now not all of us got dna from them
or at least we don't
think that we all got dna from them we
certainly didn't sing
some dna from them but that doesn't mean
we didn't descend from them you know for
a lot of us they're
they're our aunts and uncles too in the
distant past they're just uh they're
just ghosts they don't give us any dna
so
that's an example right um another thing
too where i think it comes out
is that we have i think a bit of a wrong
view of what genetics is
i think we tend to think about it like
biosauron that it can just tell us
anything we want we just kind of focus
our directing ourselves and it's true
that
genetics reveals a lot of information
about the past that we didn't see before
but it's also a lot like a telescope you
know it has it comes with really
really sharp uh tunnel vision you know
you can study like the rings of jupiter
or june from your husband i mean saturn
right the rings of saturn
creeper house rings too i don't know if
you can see them with a telescope
from earth but it won't really tell you
anything about something sitting right
next to you
and so i think that's um just one of the
paradoxes that tells us a lot of things
but there's
been massive amount of stuff done having
clarity about not just
what it tells us but what it doesn't
tell us i think is
better of what it means to be a good
scientist but it's uh often poorly
appreciated
uh as we study science
yeah uh yeah i mean one of the
interesting things
that i've i've i've been thinking about
with this lately is
we have if you look at dogs and wolves
or
dogs and or wolves and coyotes for
example they're clearly
two different species when you look at
them genetically you see that there's
not
you know you can see the distinctions
between coyotes and wolves
but we also have lots of cases of wolves
and coyotes having children together
and so there's a like genealogically you
could say that there
there's still one thing but genetically
they're
they're definitely separate things and
you do have some exceptions like you've
got the red wolf
which is actually a hybrid between
wolves and coyotes and uh
there's there's a lot of weird
interesting things like when when
a branch is is forming in the
evolutionary tree
there's a long period of time where
there's still inner reading
going on there but you might not see it
in the genetics at all
because of how how i would say the
general rule is
you don't see it um yeah yeah yeah it
just has
mathematically it has to be that it has
to be true so
you could have had you could have had
the ancestors of humans chimps and
gorillas interbreeding for a long
time before you had the actual
reproductive barriers between those
three species form
um yeah this actually becomes important
because uh
you know it turns out that hybridization
is turning out to be a very
important mechanism in evolution where
um well you know even if this idea of a
species a species is not a very well
designed
defined concept and biology
it's actually a cluster of several
concepts some of which are
some of which are not and some some only
apply to
microbes some only apply to things that
we produce actually so yeah
we don't have one definition there's not
one to rule them all
honestly it's the same for the term
human in science we have
we have uh we have cluster definitions
some of them are precise but frankly
when it comes to human most of them are
not precise definitions okay
and but yet so we still use these terms
even though they're kind of fuzzy
terms and they're unclear and um
and so the fact of the matter is that
given that reality that some of these
definitions are precise it means that uh
when it comes to speciation there are
points
in any species history in which there
are
groups of individuals where by some
definitions they really are the same
species
and by other definitions they really are
not right
right and and it's kind of a moving
target on that um and it'll change over
time and
and that that's just the reality of how
it works and now
how do we get to better understanding i
mean science means understanding well i
think one way to start doing that is to
start parsing out what some of our
definitions
are and to understand them and be clear
about which definition we're using at
different times
yeah a lot of people try to be clear
about that
um race too right because there's
different definitions of race
and that's why i think actually race is
a place where there should be
conversation about this
um in science courses to really explore
you know what are the different
definitions of race
which ones are in conflict with the
evidence which ones
are potentially consistent or you know
what we don't know and how do we even
test it
there are some definitions of race
that are not racist and that
may be consistent with evidence there's
also a large number of definitions of
race that are not uh they're just
totally inconsistent with the evidence
that a lot of people hold
yeah oh let's dive into race now
because i i mean you are right that we
are horrible at talking about race and i
think one of the reasons that we're so
bad at talking about race
is because we don't like
even when you first start to talk about
it especially when you start
talking about race from a scientific
perspective there's this immediate fear
that
is anything i'm gonna say going to be
used by racist people to
support racism um and so you have just
this
there is a extreme uh reaction to
conversations about race you know how it
is like the worst thing that could ever
happen to anyone
is having a white person be falsely
accused of racism like that's the real
problem with racism that's how a lot of
people feel about it
okay did i catch that everyone listening
and that was pure sarcasm
but i get the anxiety but the fact of
the matter is if you look at the history
everything has been used for to support
racism it is a very
it's it's just that insecure of a world
view
or that it's just grasping for authority
from everything so to
say that i mean we just you know
we just wouldn't do anything and
there's just ways to navigate this you
know you read that part of the book what
did you think about it
well you know i i so yeah one of your
chapters is just on race
and this what i loved about it was the
you summarize the history of racism in
in uh
christianity and the history of racism
in science
in a really neat way where you can see
this this back and forth that's
happening
where um you know
people want me i i do this series called
uh uh
113 questions about evolution and one of
the questions people get me
want me to ask lately is was darwin
racist
and it's such a hard thing to even start
talking about because
he was a white dude in the 1800s of
course he was racist by today's
standards
um and but also he was
super anti-slavery and it just depends
on the time period
and it it gets really complicated
um and what you pointed out is that
throughout this
conflict between science and religion
over the over the theory of evolution
there's been different ideas like
the christians used to see evolution as
a racist theory
for a period of time christians
themselves had racist theories the one
that i learned about
when i was in college was that when
north america was colonized there was a
theological argument that the native
americans were not humans
because the apostles brought the gospel
to all
people but they didn't come to america
therefore people who lived in america
were not people
and the pope had to put out an official
decree saying no
the native americans are people stop
abusing them they have human rights
and and moreover that they descend from
adam knee that's what the doctrine of
monogenesis really gets clarified right
yeah
and then you had you had these
scientific theories that
that um different races evolved from
different
types of apes so you had the uh the the
orangutans gave rise to asians is one of
the ideas
and it's gorillas gave rise to black
people
and and chimpanzees gave rights to white
people that's actually a theory that
wasn't
there yeah yeah so that
there's there's things have been all
over the place and actually
when when humans were first categorized
uh by linnaeus
he had um he had
he had us as one species but he had sub
species
for the different races and we just
you know that's no longer accepted we
consider
just one species but yeah that that was
actually one of my
one of the most interesting chapters in
the book for me was just that that
discussion of the
of the history of racism in christianity
and in
science and how actually some of the re
one of the reasons that
christians seem to hate evolution is
because they think that
it promotes a racist idea and when i
hear that
um in the past i thought that they were
just making this up completely
but it is interesting when you when you
see the history of this argument
they're just they're continuing an old
argument uh
that that was actually legitimately had
in the past so
yeah yeah i think there's a history here
i think when it comes to race
and a lot of the things frankly we tend
to be historical right
we kind of want to start with a
fleshlight now
right and kind of just go forward and
work there but ideas have histories they
have lives of their own that are behind
us right
and i think understanding the history
here isn't really helpful um
you know the debate about race didn't
actually start with darwin it started
really with the discovery of the new
world which was you know hundreds of
years before darwin right
yeah and um well obviously obviously
debates about russ did not start with
darwin
like wait darwin darwin came in
after slavery was already abolished in
england it was still going on in
america um which
uh you know we had
actually when darwin was writing the
origin of species the southern baptist
convention was forming and they were
forming because they wanted to own
slaves
that's why that's why it's called the
southern baptist convention it's because
they separated from the the larger
baptist group and so yet you have this
theologically based racism and
scientifically based racism and and like
you point
out in this book it's what's going on
here is that
racist people are desperate for
justification for their racist ideas and
so they will take from science they will
take from
uh religion and there's
almost nothing that we can do about it
like we just have to
stick to what's real and um
yeah i well so so i think
in the origins conversation i think
people who look at this
i mean it's not hard to see i mean if
you have
two eyes and you actually do a little
bit of research especially in today's
and age you find out about this history
right
yeah yeah the typical approach um
is to just avoid it except for if you're
poor tempered uh just accuse your
opponents of racism
for when you're really right right and
so that's that's the pattern of
interaction we'll see
well people will generally ignore
questions of race um you know maybe it's
because of fears of talking about i
don't think that this is generally
healthy i think a better way to
deal with this is that they start
telling this history and the story so we
can
uh really inherit the reality of and
acknowledge the reality of
the fact that everyone was racist if you
go back a few hundred years ago
even if they were well-meaning they were
racist right
and uh that's shaped society it shapes
how we talked about these things and
this is why they thought these things
even when they were well intentioned
even a lot of abolitionists were racist
but you know well yeah yeah well darwin
was he you know he comes from a family
of
uh you know like they would say
this is totally false to be clear we
know this is not true scientifically
they would think that okay we think that
slavery is wrong or we agree with that
part
the part that was wrong is they would
say that well africans who are
inherently
um not intelligent and not capable of
going to college and things like that
that's just obvious
and it's clear that you know european
civilizations work stance but even
though they're lower
than us well this is the part where the
then their object gets correct
even if they were lower than us then we
shouldn't treat them badly
and we shouldn't and we don't have a
right to own them they can be free
um and so and they and they developed
honestly in that context a notion of
universal rights and dignity right
and that's important um it meant that
they were able to acknowledge
differences
but still talk about universal rights
and dignity but if they still weren't
totally racist and
how they really judged these other races
right
well yeah darwin talks about savage um
savage races versus civilized races so
like
if you were to pull if you were to go
back in time and and have him
give us a talk on racism today he would
sound absolutely
backwards but if that's true across the
board like right i say i think this is a
helpful thing you know it's like racism
is a sin
we're all guilty we're all in all of us
have sinned we should get down to it
and so i i think that um
rather than just ignoring that and
covering it up or using as a weapon
against our opponents i think it's far
more valuable for us actually have
meaningful conversations where we
explain
you know the history of what people
believe on these things and why
and we can add empathy towards them in
their context it doesn't mean that we
need to cancel them or delete them
right yeah there was that uh that
experiment
i don't know the history well enough to
maybe even talk about this properly but
that
they had um
the in in victorian england they did
this experiment where they took
natives and tried to teach them how to
live like the queen
and then they brought their their
children and then they brought them back
to their
community hoping that they would go
teach everyone how to live like the
queen and they immediately just tore off
their clothes and ran back and just
started living how they were before and
that experiment was really popular
it was written about a lot and that it
looked to people like evidence
that their their culture was somehow
passed on through their blood not
through cultural practices
and now we know that of course they this
has to do with the age that people
were learning a new culture and and all
sorts of other things
but that that experiment
screwed up uh england england's thinking
about
race for a long time well so that's
where it's really interesting what
happened
in i would say the 1950s 60s and 70s
where
science there was a big debate that
happened about that we sometimes hear
about
in passing and we kind of lost touch
with it but it's fairly recent it's
really our parents generation of
scientists really
it's called the nature versus nurture
right right
and that's what it was about it was
about it was actually about race
it was about you know whether or not
people were intrinsically
civilized or intrinsically not it was
just nature and nurture
now what's interesting is that from
several angles
the science was really studied very
deeply and and you know alan tempenstein
was a key part of this
um but also the great april language
experiments and
it even entered popular culture and uh i
don't think he's heard of the movie
trading spaces back with any was eddie
murphy back in a long time ago in the
80s
and stuff right yeah that's all about
the nature and nurture debate right
we found out um very very solidly
is that it's not like a 50 50 thing
it is like a 99 one percent thing
towards
nurture verbal nature and that's
surprising
because in just about every other animal
you can think about
it wouldn't have come out that way it
just turned out for humans it's it's
really nurture
not nature that explains a vast majority
of differences
now there are details that are
exceptions like for example i have dark
hair that's black because of genetics
you have to understand the culture
really modifies that i don't actually
know
for example um if i meet someone if
their hair really is black or if they
dyed it black
right right and so the phenotype of
black hair
is not actually even even something like
that is not nearly as genetically
determined
as we are we're programmed to think
about it
um and that's that's that's
the illusion that we have we these
things are intrinsic
and in some ways they are like
uh for example i speak english that's
pretty intrinsic to who i
am yeah i mean i learned spanish when i
was growing up i can speak some spanish
my parents did not teach me um hindi so
i took a hindi course a little bit and i
can speak a little bit my parents didn't
teach me camel even though they speak
spoke camel
i don't know are your parents are your
parents immigrants yeah they're
immigrants yeah
they they're raising context of exposed
a lot but but you know and so
you know it seems very immutable and
unchangeable the fact that i can't speak
those languages it would be
very hard for me to go back and learn
hindi right beyond just a few words
it feels very very intrinsic like it's
something outside of my hands that i
inherited and in fact it's
true i inherited my lack of speaking
camel from my parents even though this
book came
because they didn't teach it to me right
there was like a window that i had to
learn it where i wasn't taught it
and um now the cake is like there are my
cultural contexts have been valued
hamilton so i end up learning spanish
um there's value judgments that are
there there's things that are outside my
control
um you know put into that to the point
where i didn't actually have a choice
ultimately in the matter and it's
imperative it wasn't all my choice it
was inherited
that doesn't mean it was genetic that's
still nurture
yeah and so we found out there's a quite
a bit of stuff
it turns out to be just like that like
how we speak different languages that
uh we thought that they were for a very
long time after about 500
years supporting much of colonialism
we thought that there was insurance and
not just colonial today also supporting
you know
segregation in the united states for
hundreds of years was a lot of ideas
were just
these things have to do with intrinsic
nature where
we just know for a fact now based on
clear
evidence that that's not it's really
just structure
yeah yeah let's talk a little bit about
why your book talks about racism because
the reason that your book talks about
racism is because
you've been accused that this idea that
there was people outside
of the garden that adam's descendants
mated with
opens up the door again for theological
racism
well to be clear this is how it was
presented it's like well you know
there's a slippery slope here it seems
like an inevitable way this will go is
like declaring that certain people
alive today are not fully human because
it because they're not
actually linked to adam except for that
that depends on like
i mean this is from people who purported
to completely understand what i was
saying
um and i think that they did understand
it which makes it actually far
worse i mean they really didn't
understand it but but literally i'm
saying that that's not
plausible i'm saying that everyone alive
today descends from adam and eve
so how in the world would it create
racism based on the idea that we don't
all decipher adam and eve but i'm saying
we'd all descend from adam
that doesn't make any sense there's no
logic to it but there was an emotional
logic to it right it just scares people
from talking and thinking about the idea
so i think that was always really behind
it
well okay let me let me uh
play devil's advocate here i would say
that
uh there definitely are people i mean
still grasping for reasons to be racist
and a lot of those people are christian
and a lot of them are not but that
i think what the with the this the fear
here is that uh we're going to give them
something to hold on to maybe they could
say oh well
there's no there's no way to prove that
this group of people
is related to adam therefore there's no
way to prove that this group of people
really is people
right um well that's the backwards way
of putting on a couple levels first of
all just because you don't relate to
it's adam and eve it doesn't mean you
don't have human worth and dignity and
actually what i argue in the book is
quite the opposite up there that the
people who
don't discern adam and eve may not be
the humans of whom scripture is talking
about they're not
they're not what the story of scripture
is about but they're fully human-like
they're they have full human worth and
dignity so
i don't i don't actually think that
that's possible um but if you get
down to the core of it what i'm arguing
is that the racist idea of polygenicity
the idea that some of us descend from
some people and other people don't it's
just actually nonsense
um and so it is actually in conflict
with the vast majority of racist
views of origins out there and you look
at this historically too so i'm not the
very
first person to recognize this like you
know including um
articles and citing articles um uh for
nature in 2004 and a book that came out
um in 2001 called mapping human history
by gene wilson
have you heard of that book uh you open
a great person interview too
he's an atheist great guy um and he kind
of came to us here with this book and
his
his initial reaction to thinking about
this and kind of was looking at it was
going
well all the views about race are
totally nonsense actually we're all one
family and it was a very
anti-racist emotional response he had
and that's
and that's how actually most people who
have looked at it have felt and if you
go after even back to um
you know henry kendall who was probably
the first person
um you know that i could find that
really kind of picked up on this
it was like in 1889 or so he published
an article where he recognized recent
human ancestry of course he didn't have
um all the genetics back game and things
like that like we have now you know his
initial reaction too was like a
profoundly anti-racist reaction i think
the fact of the matter is that it shows
that we're all connected in one family
well one race one blood
humanities and so to stay then
that that affirms monogenesis which is
like this historical doctrine that stood
against racism
in the church for a long time um
i mean if it's not if it's not race
fading it's just profoundly ignorant
well okay but here here's what i'm
saying about your
so if if we do your thought experiment
and we assume that adam and eve uh
were created especially six thousand
years ago
and then they started interbreeding with
the people outside the garden
which had evolved there's you could say
that maybe there's something special
about adam and eve because they were
handcrafted by god and and you could say
this could open up racism towards
non-atomites
i guess you could say or um but just
think about that for a moment
there's no non-atomized here on earth
well well
but but your your theory doesn't have
any way to prove or
i shouldn't call your theory but you're
the
no there's no way to prove there's no
way to disprove that i think the
agreement
is is that across the entire globe
everyone descends from anatomy that is
what really the science shows with the
one exception of possibly tasmania
well yeah but but tasmania is not a race
so we're not talking about race we're
talking about one isolated place
possibly which is not which is debatable
and the evidence might show otherwise
in the future we're not talking about
africa so we're private africans versus
chinese people we're not talking about
any of that stuff
um and we're not talking about native
americans uh we're talking about what
it's
it's that's not racism that would be
um that would be like anti-tan
tasmanianism which was certainly a thing
that was horribly wrong
but even then now today like there's
been
there's been i mean there isn't any pure
tasmanians anymore yet they were knocked
out with a huge genocide right
yeah and i think everyone should agree
that that genocide was wrong so but
so we're even we're not even talking
about people in our lives today
uh nothing initially we're talking about
people may be alive in the recent
past but not allowed today so we're not
talking about racism really
we're talking earlier about how do we
think about um the rights and dignity of
people that don't descend from another
need but i would say that that's no
different than talking about how do we
think about the human rights and dignity
of people of aliens from another planet
like if if if there were martians or if
aliens like showed up in an interstellar
starship
tomorrow right and let's say we could
find out how to communicate with them
and they really
had a different origin with us would
that automatically mean that they had no
rights and no dignity
and i think if that's the case that'd be
a big problem right
but that's not how we're thinking about
those things
in that case we're not saying that the
existence of aliens
is support for racism right well
i so i what i got when i was
reading this is that
a racist person could grab hold of this
as an excuse
i don't think that anyone has yet and i
i doubt that anyone will and so i
actually think that the
the criticism against your thinking
the race based criticism is a red
herring
uh i i understand that it's
possible that someone could pick that up
and say oh well you can't prove that
your lineage is related to adam
therefore
i'm gonna say that it's not um
but this something hasn't happened yet
no one's using your
argument all the way around you can turn
that person you haven't proved your
your lineage in the sense from adam name
so maybe yeah
it's like like how would you single out
one group to do that one
yeah you know
here's the thing though racist people
don't tend to be all that uh
careful in their reasoning right
basically an idea
there's a slippery slope to racism no no
no
race is key in on something and anything
that we put out there that make it
racist
yes because that's what racists do but
what is that trying to say exactly
right right um i want to say i want to
talk about something else that that i
loved about your book
is that i felt like okay when i was a
mormon i felt like uh
we weren't supposed to really ask these
types of questions about the origin of
adam and eve it was like
it was i felt very uncomfortable um
doing that and i see a lot of christians
get uncomfortable doing that and even
what i saw in mormonism was that mormons
are horrible at
producing good sci-fi because they can't
think outside the box that was for
galactica
yeah yeah it was that glass it was
written by morgan's the original version
so there are some exceptions that i
think there's
there's so battlefield galactica there's
also um
i didn't consider it good sci-fi but
twilight was written by a mormon
oh my gosh the vampire stuff um
but but i i did see like uh
so it and and now we have these
questions about artificial intelligence
and
do we have if we create strong ai
are there ethical concerns and i feel
like
a lot of these questions um at least
mormons are kind of
like they don't even get to participate
in these conversations because
their theology is so um
restrictive and i feel like i feel like
the way that your
your concept opens up theology to
consider evolution and to consider
what human is and even consider that
aliens could be
human or could be could have human
dignity
or that ais could have human dignity
this is something that's
i feel like is um it's opening people up
to
explore these things and feel
comfortable while exploring it and i
think that's
super cool oh thanks yeah i think that's
the fun of it
we don't have it all figured out right
um theology is not supposed to be this
sort of fixed set of like
answers that you just kind of recite off
people it's supposed to be this grand
conversation where we're trying to
figure it out when we know some things
but we don't know others and we're
trying to make sense of the world
together
science is too i mean we know some
things we don't know they're just trying
to make sense of the world together
that conversation the conversation about
you know life on other planets
about uh you know our ancient human
ancestors about
the possibility of like a artificial
mind
yeah i mean that's the conversation
that we could be having we shouldn't be
afraid of questions you know one of the
they've done surveys on why people leave
the church or
leave the faith yeah one of the most
cited statements that people make is
that you know
the church that i was in which means i
went within
it's really through really encountering
who jesus is really and and
you know what he what he did and i mean
he found evidence for that he goes to
the dead but really in that
like a confidence that i can actually be
uncertain about other things and
questions aren't threatening
that's fun yeah uh
i want to open up to questions everybody
uh we're gonna kind of wrap things up
here i've got
um one more question for you
while people are writing in their
personal questions
like what parting words do you have for
any christians who are struggling to
maintain their faith as they learn about
evolution
like what's your advice to them
and and actually we didn't really talk
about your personal
like how it is that you came to accept
that evolution was a thing
uh like well you know maybe
clearly i'd love to do a series of
videos and looking at the evidence of
revolution that'll be really fun yeah
yeah
um so we should talk about that um
but for me you know i was raised in a
young earth creationist context and i
got really connected to
anti-evolutionism and really
a big um a big part of that that
ideology is this
this false teaching that
we know christianity is true because
evolution is false
and nowhere in the bible doesn't say
that and
what i think is actually true instead
it's far more encouraging is that
whether or not evolution is true whether
it's true or false
whether um scientists are entirely
confused or they've learned something
and
then you're kind of confused about the
science uh
jesus is worth following he's good and
because god raised him from the dead
that i know that god exists he's good
and wants to be known and i think if you
really
look at who jesus is in scripture and if
you look at the evidence uh
that's out there for for for for him
i think you can come to confident faith
in jesus even when you have a lot of
questions and uncertainty about origins
and i think
that's probably how it's supposed to be
yeah
what what did you feel tension
when you were first talking about
evolution i mean i uh i did i mean
there's a
there's an article i wrote called um
finding confident faith in science where
i just talked about my my story on that
um
where yeah i was reading that context
and so i remember
just an immense amount of
just emotional turmoil that wasn't
necessary like i remember
i mean i was drawn to science but i just
felt the tension around conflict
but there was a point where i found a
lot of uh
comfort in you know all these
anti-evolutionist generous creationist
arguments right
i met a younger creationist when i was a
kid he's a young creationist himself
he's
he was skeptical of creation science and
he basically said you know i don't know
i've looked into it i think
and this is what he said it was actually
a very um very thoughtful thing he said
he said you know i think that um i think
that
evolution could have been true it's just
that i know from scripture
that i mean it actually makes more sense
than those arguments those arguments are
kind of straw meaning
it makes a lot more sense it could be
true it's just i know from scripture
that it's not what happened
that's what makes that very benign thing
yeah
and i burst into tears
and it could like that protective
barrier of how evolution is absurd
that's how i know this
it just all fell apart right there you
felt the kind of difference
it was a disaster and like it's poor
this poor man who said this very kind
thing i was trying to sit there put me
back together and my parents were like
what's going on what did you say to him
and so yeah i i felt that and i think it
took a long time to work through it for
me um
and i had a christian i said
part of it was uh really uh
really seeing what scripture said and
making sense of that
um and really reading genesis closely i
found out that i've been told
a lot of things genesis said that it
didn't actually say that that really
helped to understand
um it doesn't actually say a lot of
things that people say it says
if you have to read what it actually
says even water away it's not a conflict
that was one thing the other thing is
actually looking at the science for
myself and this is something where i'm
really privileged because i was actually
you know at that point i was like in a
level scientist i mean a phd program
actually when i
when you know the human genome came out
and uh and the chimpanzee genome came
out i was actually trying to go look at
it and understand it and ask questions
look at it and i'm just telling you
it really looks like common descent
maybe you're going to just dispute
common attempt but it really looks like
humans share common ancestry
god could have created us in a different
way if he wanted to but he didn't this
is what he did so why
and um and then the last thing is just
understanding um
what is you know what is the place i
should put my confidence is it really an
anti-evolution arguments
that leads to very unstable faith if you
want a confident faith the place to put
your confidence is what god did through
history by revealing jesus
i mean i understand that that's not a
very secular thing to say but you did
that's my personal beliefs but that's
that's
that's where what i think
the scientific reason you believe in
jesus
but okay so
i don't want to cut you off but we do
have some more questions here
go for it yeah how are you doing on
um towards ai
aren't the vegan arguments more more
germane more proximal
so basically what he's saying is
shouldn't we
shouldn't we be focusing on ethics
towards
i think it's also very debatable whether
or not we're ever going to get strong ai
so sure yeah i agree i mean the same
thing can be said about uh thinking
about disabilities and people with
disabilities and making sure we have a
real
thought through this thing uh really
carefully
um yeah we can talk about those things i
think uh
veganism one point i think is pretty
interesting actually
is if you talk to like hardcore young
creationists and
really press them on it especially with
the geological adam and eve
sometimes they will actually be clear
and recognize that it actually isn't
about what scripture in the bible says
it's actually about their theology
and it's not even about adam and eve and
jesus
it's really about death before the fall
and so what they want to say is that
animal death
ex did not exist across the globe before
adam and eve sinned
and so and so what comes with that is
like a theology that says that there's a
unmitigated evil to any animal death
and what's interesting about this is
that these same young christians
almost always will be steak eaters
and so the question is but wait a minute
if that's what you think why aren't you
a vegan now that's where i think
seventh-day adventism comes in because
they tend to be on diaspora creation
that's actually where the theology
originates you don't actually see that
theology historically in the christian
church
you see it really arised fairly recently
in seventh-day adventism
and they tend to be vegetarians
and so it's interesting so i mean this
is one of those places where there's
this
conflict between the practice of young
creationism and their historical roots
which creates like a conflict and
there's theology
coherence so they uh think that uh they
think that uh
killing animals is wrong in the distant
past
but not now i heard a christian argument
against
veganism saying that because jesus ate
fish
we would be putting ourselves above
jesus
well i don't know i mean i think i think
veganism can be situational there are
some people who are vegans
because they think that eating animals
is wrong in any context but there are
other people who are vegans because they
think
given how animals are
produced here in our current context
and upon the suffering for these
and that they objected on those grounds
that's a very different sort of thing
that means they can imagine a better
world
in which or they can even imagine some
of them i've talked to they can imagine
like if they actually
had confidence that a particular chicken
was had a good life
and it was ethically handled throughout
it and it wasn't supporting that evil
industry then they wouldn't have a
problem eating i mean they would maybe
wouldn't elect to
just because you know they're accustomed
to not eating it but they would have a
problem with that and
that's it it's a very different sort of
veganism that
that frankly what veganism was in india
when it first arose right so there it
was actually an intrinsic
religious belief um so yeah but i do
think it's important to think about
these things
um and to work through what actually
makes things wrong and you know what
that means to that
imagine a better one i tend to be
sympathetic i would say it's a second
type of veganism
where it doesn't think that eating
animals is intrinsically wrong
but um but it has serious ethical
objections to how
animals are treated today i think that's
a sort of uh
we call it maybe uh to use some uh
what i think it could be hopeful
language it's like it's a type of
prophetic veganism saying that you know
there could be a better world
in which we created animals in a better
way and
and that that's the world that they're
holding off
what oh yeah i mean without animals yeah
i do vegans eat
like the cultured meat i wonder do they
uh it just depends
i think
it was interesting when the whole uh
impossible burger came out
there was some debate where some it was
so meat like that some
i mean i don't know i mean there's some
uh
saying that this is kind of like
cheating i mean this is just like the
real thing i mean
they feel bad about it which is
interesting actually it shows that
there's like some sort of a moral
there's like a social component to it or
a perception component to it
beyond natural ethics the vegan world is
super diverse
yeah it's diverse i said there's a range
there's a range
are you vegan no no i well
i don't i don't buy meat no
or dairy or anything like that but i do
eat it when i'm when someone else makes
it i don't have
i don't have deep convictions and i
actually love meat so i get excited when
someone makes it for me
but i don't i don't participate my house
in uh
some barbecue for you how about that
but i yeah i have
and my my issue with it is like we are
raising animals in such a horrible way
first of all it's not sustainable um
it's it's opening us up to
pandemics it's not necessary
for most people for some people it is
actually there's there are legitimate
health concerns
oh but look we could be eating meat in a
way that is more sustainable
than that of concern for
um the well-being of animals i mean i'd
say from a christian point of view
look even i i think it's very hard to
make a case for
absolute veganism but i do think that
it's possible to come away from
scripture without having a concern for
how we treat animals
um i mean if you look at how it talks
about the slaughter of animals
it was designed to actually minimize the
pain and suffering
of those we weren't supposed to like
cause these animals to suffer
and if you look at how we treat animals
it really
can be very much crossing that line so
like you know that's not
that's not right i mean even if we're
gonna eat them they treat them
right yeah it's really absurd what we've
done
with our industry we've just had uh
we just don't have the motivation the
motivations are
mass production so that everyone can
have access to cheap meat
and that's a great thing for everyone to
have access that really good
quality protein that's awesome except
for that we've
sacrificed like most things that happen
in a slaughterhouse or in in
how animals are manufactured like i used
to work in a chicken farm
there's no way that an individual just
wake up in the morning and do that sort
of thing to a chicken
like we're not we're not cool in that
way
but you go and you do it because this is
how the industry works like
we had chickens cram the little tiny
coop in the dark
so tightly that my job was to come in
and clean up after the chickens were
removed for slaughter
and there was chickens that were pecked
to death
their eyes are ripped out we've
selectively bred them to grow so quickly
that sometimes their legs will break
and then they get eaten alive by their
friends
it's like because we put them in this
weird situation where they're
um and so so we would do stuff i would
do stuff
you know working in this industry that
there was no way i would get up and
do that on my own but i was told that it
was how you do it
so i just did it uh
and that that's uh it's absurd i mean
meanwhile like
my friends i lived in tennessee for a
while i had had friends that were like
true hillbillies
lived off the land didn't know how to
read and
they they had animals and they respected
their animals
in it in a way that was very different
than what i saw when i was working at
the farm
and they were hunters as well and they
respected the animals they were hunting
in a way that i never saw at the farm
it's just
it's just it's
yeah so i think i think this is a place
where it's what it is it's from an
economic point of view it's a negative
externality there's like no
cost to treating animals poorly and
there's a
there's a there's a gain and so you know
corporations are actually legally
obligated to
then mistreat animals to protect their
their
shareholders i mean it's a constant case
for you know
uh where you know having industry
oversight and regulations
to manage this is really probably the
only way i'll get resolved
and there's big progress there and there
needs to be more progress
yeah that's my actually would be helpful
what
my apologies people said that i was
muted i just yeah
i had actually muted myself there to to
youtube
but uh so yeah that
maybe ah well i'll talk about veganism
on some other
video but uh i've actually had that
question asked me to me a lot
is um you know did we evolve to eat meat
or
is there's there's an argument from
evolution saying that
if you look at our teeth and our
stomachs that we evolved to be vegans
um and that's actually that's kind of
folk science
that that's not true i mean it's pretty
clear about eating
meat in particular or cooked food too
was a core part of evolution it was a
core part of our ancestry but
what's fair to say that we've evolved to
eat high concentrations of protein
whether or not that has to come from
animals now with modern technology
is obviously we don't have to eat meat
anymore we
we can eat all sorts of other products
that give us that same amount of protein
but in our evolutionary history we
definitely went through a high
meat consumption phase there's no
there's no doubt about that in the
fossil record
will also um with also like you know
fasting and and um you know like
intermittent fasting type stuff too
i mean i think that's true i think the
reality though is i think we kind of
lose track of
how much we've reshaped the environment
chickens like we have now
we've never existed in the past but the
same thing is true like there's never
been a broccoli until very recent
there's never been a process
or where you know all the grains that
we're eating didn't exist
until you know very very recently like
you're talking about excel less than 10
thousand years ago which is like a blink
of an eye from an evolutionary
we were we were like
we weren't eating any of the things that
we eat now
right like like everything we've had
is just like all the plants that we eat
are totally different now
right and um
and that has had a lot of positive
things like
starvation we still see in the world but
that's just because we're horrible to
one another
there's no reason that anyone should
starve anymore right now people do
in the past is because there wouldn't be
enough food but famines are kind of a
thing of the past
when you think about on a global scale
we just don't we just don't treat each
other well
yeah i related to treating each other
well
i've got a question about aliens and how
we would treat them so
speaking of aliens wouldn't josh's idea
mean any alien humanoid
cannot be related to adam and eve and so
could not share our favored status
um that that's another so the favorite
status thing
is coming out a lot here i think well i
didn't say favorite that wasn't puberty
so favor is a value judgment no one no i
mean i didn't say favored
i think that what would be true is that
they're not
i mean if they're human they're not
human the same way we are maybe they
have full human minds and all that we
can talk to them they're fully rational
um maybe god has a different sort of
relationship with them i don't know or
maybe
um maybe we'll figure it out when it
happens but they're not
quite the same as us i think a really
helpful science fiction
for thinking about this actually is um
it's dark
right well okay so
let me point one thing out real quick i
think that the chance of finding a
humanoid alien
is ridiculously low star trek taught us
that it's high but of course
in reality an alien could be something
so foreign to us that we wouldn't even
think that we're looking at a life form
if we saw it so um possible
but let's just pretend that star trek
the star trek method is the thing and we
when we meet like
we meet klingons right yeah so okay
penguins
human is a really important question by
some definitions of human
they're not human by other definitions
they are
yeah and i think a far more salient
question is do they have
what we call human rights and dignity
and i think uh
actually um we should think that they do
now when you think about the cultural
context of what star trek is written i
think it's important
because at that time everyone believed
in polygenesis
not everyone most people didn't
polygenesis that
that actually you know african americans
were kind of
different subspecies or different
species than other than white people
imagine during the time of segregation
and what's really embedded in star trek
in the early ones from the 1960s
is a really strongly anti-racist message
right
yep where um i mean they have
horror who's black that's on the that's
actually on the on the ship right and
there's like the very first interracial
kiss on tv was between kirk and uhura
yeah but uh but there's also this clear
analogy that's layered on top of it of
other races and other being other
species
and uh and really talking about
conflicts between them and how that
conflict is going to be resolving by
bringing them back into our community
and even having um having children with
them ends up being
thing and it was actually fairly radical
um
that uh i mean it's it's completely
against armor rays right now
um even a secular context but if you
think about this is going backwards in
time to the 1960s because this is right
after 950ds and yet
during like the free love move and all
that but but kirk is
going and having you know is going in
and sleeping with
with with aliens every opportunity he
gets
yeah that was that was actually a very
strong cultural commentary
of like of a lack of aversion towards
them
yeah yeah and so it was beyond just
saying we're gonna give you humans the
rights and dignity
like the the storyline was was there
like you know he doesn't have a version
for them and no one
was saying that this is bestiality or
something like that or like they're not
i mean how could you do that what if you
have a kid and then eventually you're
gonna get to the 80s with
all that then you start to see these
half hang on half you know
human kids being formed right yeah yeah
i'm going through voyager right now
that's that's the one that i'm on
see that it is a commentary on race and
so i think what
we can get from that is that's an
alternate world it's not our world right
right but even if it was true
even if it was true that um on earth
that there were different races to the
point of having different species of
human on earth
it's not inevitable that we'd be racist
that we could still respond to that by
treating people with human rights
and dignity and without treating other
people with a version and still just
you know having that star trek or world
that is like uh
logically possible the reality is is
that when we encounter people on the
other side of the globe
about 500 years ago we took a different
path
and we uh we colonized them and we uh we
treated ourselves as better than them
and we uh we looked down on them and
then that carried over for generations
that's the reality of what happened and
that's what we're inheriting and working
through but it's not inevitable
yeah i think that's uh
let's see direct questions
if i missed any of your direct questions
uh rewrite them real quick here
i'm trying to go through there's almost
everything with my name tagged in it
recently was telling me that i was muted
[Laughter]
so let's see but yeah i i feel like this
is
the the the ethics the ethics that we
have towards other animals
so there's been a movement recently
within
um animal rights to consider apes
other other apes to be to have
personhood
and human rights so we stop using them
for medical research
we stop um i think people actually want
to stop eating them out of zoos
and i so i used to volunteer at zoos and
i can't remember if it was in tennessee
or if it was in oregon because i worked
at the
knoxville zoo in tennessee and i worked
at the portland zoo when i lived in
oregon
but there was a chimpanzee that had
invented a word for human which is like
this
it was basically pointing out our bubble
heads right
because we had these giant foreheads
compared to chimps
and i was being trained there as a
volunteer and i was there after hours
and this chimpanzee was talking with her
um
her trainer in signs and she was
pointing at us and she was angry and she
was doing this
and it turns out she was angry that the
bubbleheads were looking at her
when the zoo was closed she understood
that she had a shift
a day shift where she had to let people
look at her and she was angry when i was
looking at her when people were looking
at her after
her shift and this like blew my mind
this chimpanzee understands that she has
to deal with us for a while
and this is her private time and we're
invading her private time
that was crazy to me but there's this um
and there is this movement to to
consider these animals to have
personhood for legal rights
and i i wonder how well
yeah what about your thoughts on legal
details so much is
just to say that um
that there's a paradox here that um
we're far more alike um in other animals
than we tend to think but we're also far
more different
than chimpanzees than knowing you might
think when we have like
i mean it's a paradox it's both those
things at the same time
um it's really interesting looking back
at the
great ape language experiments and
looking at those and kind of seeing how
those play out i think that that paradox
really comes to the forefront
look at those yeah the second thing is i
think that we have to recognize
that part of what it means to be human
is that we tend to anthropomorphize
things and we also tend to dehumanize
things
and we have an amazing opportunity to do
both that's paradox as well
so on one hand we can do we can we can
just be thoughtless about
really horrific things that we'll do to
animals just because we've totally
dehumanized
the point they're just nothing yeah we
do that to other people too i mean
when you get to other people right my
grandpa was in world war
ii and he said that immediately uh
he hated japanese people and he thought
it was funny when they would die
and he's like he had this you know he's
17 years old and he's thrown into world
war
ii and his when he got married
his wife was so disgusted by this that
um
she forced him to hang out with japanese
people until he got over it
and uh it was it was amazing hearing him
talk about how he could do these things
to people
without any feeling whatsoever it was
just
it's our enemy i mean it's part of how
we are as humans i mean it's it's kind
of
it's kind of crazy that we can do that
right you know you know we have
an amazing capacity it seems like it's
in direct conflict partly because it is
to anthropomorphize things
and be an inferred humanness where there
isn't humans
so i mean we'll hear a bump in the night
and we'll infer a lot of things about it
right
could just be like a house
um and and i think the reality is
i mean we'll also look at an animal and
we'll think it's thinking something
which
it may not be right i think especially
where science can really help us too
to really understand and to really
understand
you know more about what animals really
are experiencing what they're not
what really is suffering for them and
what really isn't and what really
is uh the right way to treat them i
think part of what's going on with the
great ape experiments is that there's
been a lot more
awareness that they um they have um
i mean a lot of what we put them through
is suffering and it's not necessary
yeah um and so
there'll be debate about what actually
is necessary i mean it seems like um
the idea of taking captive bred uh
chimpanzees and and great apes and
keeping them in captive
um in good environments is not
necessarily a bad thing
and i think that's also probably going
to be important in some contexts for
some types of non-invasive research
yeah jane goodall has been doing well
her foundation has been
just what they're trying to do is
document
okay what is stressing out chimpanzees
what is not
because it's not like we want to just
make them just live in the tiny
shrinking parts of the forest where they
can still live like stressful too right
let's how how do we uh how do we invite
them into
into a shared environment with us in a
way that's
not going to stress them out these sorts
of understanding based approaches are
better than
like these blanket blunt rules look i
mean
one i mean a lot of us have heard about
the tiger king one of the key
uh uh pieces of evidence behind it
which is surprising is that i should
have more um domestic
tigers and great cats than there are in
the wild right now yeah yeah
domestic lions domestic tigers then
there are tigers in the wild
and so um one solution is to say we
don't ever keep them captive but then
that means that
there's really risk of being lost
entirely as
i don't know if a species better world i
think a better world would be one notice
that they're not lost but if they're
going to be lost you know we have to
choose like you know there it'd be great
to preserve
that future generations so i don't i
wouldn't go so far saying i shouldn't be
captains but the bigger question though
is like how do we uh how do we do this
how do we captivate them in a way that
isn't cruel
right right and i think that's where the
focus should
be personally and to really and i don't
think that it's not like why
how to how would you as a human feel if
this is done to you well you would
that's
that's absurd well you really should be
thinking well how would the tiger feel
about this
right yeah it's going to be good for the
tiger
yeah yeah you're right and and jane
goodall's work
the the i guess it's the leaky
foundation their
their work is very very um
careful they're they're just trying to
observe things they you that we
have all this observation in the wild
that jane goodall started and we've been
doing this
in zoos now and we're we're trying to
really link
you know what are the gestures that
they're showing and what do those
gestures actually mean
um are there things we can do that make
them more comfortable less comfortable
because with the
one of the problems with with keeping
dolphins for example dolphins look like
they're constantly smiling
and so they can be in extreme misery and
you think they're so cute and you're
just playing with them and pitting them
because they they look like they're
smiling and we just pretend that that
means that they're happy we
we can't not see a smile when you look
at a dolphin
and the same thing what they're finding
is happening with chimpanzees
we we misread their emotions all the
time we misread their
what's what their intentions are uh
so yeah it's very careful study to try
and figure out how we do this
yeah and i think that that's really good
i mean i think it's also pretty uh
and i think if you really care about
that i think we should care about we
should be really cautious about
some of the extremes too that want to
push for policy or uh or denigrate
things without actually understanding
and i think the real key to these things
is going to be understanding i mean if
we can come to a better understanding of
things then we can make more rational
policy
and in fact a lot of times people will
do things more we'll just
we'll do some things at least
voluntarily if they just understand
right
yep yep that's great i didn't know
exactly what they were doing but it
sounds great
yeah we're not really getting any
direct questions here and uh but yeah i
think
this was a really cool this was really
fun conversation
thanks for having me and it's great to
meet your audience too yeah your your
book
your book was was really great i i'm
trying to think
who i would recommend your book to i
think i'd definitely recommend it
to people who are teaching evolution
professionally
anyone who's teaching evolution
professionally to be aware of this
this i would say you should definitely
read this book
any christians who are struggling as
they're trying to learn about evolution
when they're feeling that anxiety i
would say they should definitely read
this book
and then anyone in the secular world
who's just curious about
how christians are starting to think
about evolution
i think should read this and i'm not
joking when i say this i think that
this could end up i think if you
continue on with this
and promoting this idea i think it could
be
a staple just a boring fact that kids
memorize
when they're even in mormon sunday
school or catholic sunday school or
in islamic like it i think it could
actually end up being universally
accepted within the abrahamic religions
almost uh once people get past
this like that would do a lot of good
for for society if that happened
right and i yeah i think obviously we're
not going to get ken ham to be like okay
you're right
let me shut down my ark encounter that's
cost me 100 million dollars but
here's the thing where it'd be
interesting to talk to you about you're
right ken ham won't agree but i'll tell
you what
a lot of his base is going to be
attracted to it and i think
the key issue is um you know
you know how do you help them see it how
do you show them that alternative
so yeah um
i think like i said i think there's an
opportunity it'd be fun to do
um even if it doesn't touch on anime per
se but to start out with some
you know to think through what videos
could look like that are dealing with
the geological ancestry stuff right
that'd be really cool yeah yeah yeah
just videos i i wanted to talk about one
more
critique from faizal ali
have you have you read his critique of
you yeah he's a friend of mine yeah
he's one of the people who was totally
negative is going to come around
yeah so he says that you are seeking to
circumscribe science and install a
firewall between it and religion by the
way he
in this article he's saying this as a as
a as an insult i i think
yes such that each discipline works in
relative isolation from each
other as such i do not see the scenario
holding much attraction for creationists
of various stripes
whose true ambition is to bring science
to heal and make it subservient
to scriptural revelation that firewall
thing that he's using as a criticism i
think that well that's
that yeah that is kind of the point like
we don't
well we don't have to make this
conversation with each other i want to
be in conversation
right that's not a firewall that's not
saying you do your thing and what i'm
saying is that science is telling us
stuff that's
legitimate it's important it's just not
what scripture told us scripture might
be telling us other things that are
important
well the firewall aspect of this though
the firewall aspect of this is like i
can
even if i don't yet know how my my
religious views
mesh with the science i can get really
interested in my study of the gospels of
jesus christ
you know and how that applies to my life
and i can get really interested in the
study of evolution
and i don't have i i can just remember
that oh these aren't necessarily in
conflict so i can actually dive in and
enjoy them both
fully uh that is what i want i wouldn't
call that a firewall
but he's he's i think half right i think
he's correct
that um that ken ham you know nathaniel
jameson
oh you know the anti-evolutionist out
yeah that now there's like a core
founding principle that they hate
evolution yeah they're not going to like
this because it's a threat
yeah basically uh it basically shows
that a lot of the reason why they oppose
evolution isn't really legitimate
yeah they're not gonna like it and they
want to actually
impose certain things on education and
i'm
probably taking that away from them you
know but
when rock knows that that's not actually
where a lot of creation is a lot of
creationists
are more than happy to uh
to consider a way to come to a less
oppositional relationship with evolution
so yeah they're not about opposing
things as much as affirming things
and for those that are more about
affirming things and opposing things
then i think this has been um
this has been like uh this has been
something that they're very thankful for
yeah i i think that yeah i think
i think that a lot of the creationist
movement
there are very few people that base
their faith on young earth creationism
like the ken ham version of creation
very few people base their faith on that
except for
like i mean ken ham even claims that he
doesn't base his faith on that
it's based on jesus christ right but
he's dumped so much money
and so much of his like um ego into it
that i i don't see i don't see him
backing down um
you brought up nathaniel jeansen uh yeah
i'm i'm actually curious as to
what what he would end up doing actually
so he and i are friends he gave me a
signed copy of his book he gave me a
tour of you know
respond to any of my emails it's
interesting um i think
that he i don't necessarily know that
that's
him doing that versus aig like i think
i think other people have been able to
get in contact with him on the same
things i think he uh i think he doesn't
want to engage with me
he did say online that he read my book
and his main objection to it was
that i didn't cite his book oh
i thought it would be kind of absurd
because uh my book is not about engaging
with younger creationism it's about
engaging mainstream science so
his book is off topic but he was like
why didn't you cite my book on adam and
eve
um yeah well it's kind of off topic but
my impression of him i mean we you know
we hung out for a day he gave me a tour
of the creation museum he was awesome
and he wanted to do a presentation with
me a joint presentation together
where we were what we were going to do
is just talk about where
we have agreement and where we have
disagreement and aig wouldn't let him do
it
because because i i don't have a phd and
they didn't want to
use their phd to develop people without
pcs
yeah so it's i i understand aig
like the answers he'll answer your
emails that's great maybe put us in
contact maybe
maybe it is a dude that won't talk it
won't do that i i
don't think that's it but yeah that's
great
i don't know i my impression of him is
that uh
he well i actually think he might be
kind of like uh i i think he probably
has extremely high iq he's
he seems to me like he's super
intelligent
and hyper focused on an idea that i
think obviously is a dead end
from my perspective and world view i
don't know what your thoughts are
on his um his research but i i think
he's a guy who has a great degree but he
hasn't
and i like to actually that he's
published a lot and at least creation
struggle so you can actually see the
details of what he's done
um but you know he like just on a
technical level
he he he just made a lot of mistakes
yeah yeah he has
i mean this this book has lots of i mean
that he's
yeah that's that's a conversation for
another time but
i think it's actually one person what
joel duff has pointed out joel duff is
is one of the most important people
about creationist ideas he reads
like everything across the spectrum um
he's pointed out that um
one thing that's notable about um
jameson's work is that no one in the
creationist world
has cited him or said positive things
about it
which is surprising like pod wood hasn't
i mean other creations haven't actually
come out positive but i mean i think
that is a real puzzle actually what's
going on i think part of what's going on
is that um um is that i think
i mean it's possible i mean what joel
would say that i think that they
that they kind of recognize that there's
issues with what he's doing
i mean i don't know if that's for sure
the case or not but that is kind of the
impression that it sort of gives
yeah he yeah
i don't i don't know how other
creationists would i mean i in youtube
comments what
i see him cited all the time from
creationists
so like layman creationists are
um using his work a lot now it's
it's now picked up some steam yeah i
think that that's true
he's being promoted by aig i mean i
think the key question that's why i
think the fact that he hasn't responded
to
emails from me is important um
why won't he actually respond to a
christian as a scientist that's making
space for
you know you that he cares about why why
is he gonna want to even respond i think
that
that's a problem um that's not how
science works
um you know just on a professional level
um
it makes sense if we want to reach out
to you i mean you have a large following
and gives exposure to his ideas he would
gain
far more from uh doing a joint event
from you than you probably was in
and also during you know
you know it makes sense why you do it
it's a little surprising angie said no
but i can understand the reason why yeah
yeah they're they're
i mean he's kind of like uh the
superhero and creationism right like the
person who actually went through and got
the
the degree and is now with others though
i mean there's also
there's a lot of a lot of them that have
done that um
i think what's notable there's
i mean there are a lot of creationists
that have species
not high proportion not not in a high
proportion
we know about there's probably 30 or so
but in terms of 30 or 40 but there's a
large number that
are incognito and i have jobs and second
institutions just don't tell you
um that they're not creationists i think
i think what's notable about
um jameson is that he's actually being
promoted by aig that's what's really
gotten him
yeah so um
i mean that's really i think where it is
like in congress like stanford
johnson stanford has had kind of a
different approach on this and
rob carter they're not really um they're
not really
uh promoted by ages and most people
don't know about them i mean except for
the genetic entropies
not on stuff on out of me yeah
it's an interesting world i again i
don't want to take too much of your time
but
you have done discussions
with james tour and michael behe
um and
doug axe too doug x i i haven't seen i
i didn't see your conversation with doug
axe but i i i just want to say that i
really appreciate you talking with us
with these people especially with with
james tour um
james tour and i have a little bit of a
history of talking back and forth to
each other i want to be able to do a
presentation with him jointly
sometime about it or is that over
sorry what are we on air still i'm just
curious oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we are on
there still
um but he um
uh james actually advised on one of my
chemistry videos a while ago
and he he used to do a lot of science
outreach in chemistry actually wouldn't
when i first started youtube i
bumped into james to her stuff he was
doing uh he was doing molecules that are
shaped like
people and to get kids excited about
chemistry
um and so i was i was really like
saddened by his uh
what i see as anti-science stuff that
he's been doing lately
but uh yeah i was happy to see that
you're talking to him
and and michael behe so yeah i
i just uh i really appreciate that
you're doing that yeah it's been good
and i'd say it's really important to put
michael b he and james torn a different
different bucket yeah
they're both working for intelligent
design right now at least i think james
tour is working in contracts with them
but he's not like an actual intelligent
design fellow
right yeah i think
i mean i don't yeah i think he
you know there's a history here it's
it's kind of complicated
and it's probably not my story to tell
um
yeah but i think that
i mean there's i think he has some
legitimate points and i don't think
those legitimate points have always been
received and
addressed in appropriate ways right so
you know when things kind of spiral from
there then i think these are kind of
social situations we get but the fact
that matters is he's a really legitimate
scientist
um that really
has some ideas that origin of life
researchers are going
to disagree with and um and
but here i guess he has a right to put
those ideas out i mean and if they're
going to work they're going to work
among scientists
and you're not actually arguing for
what a lot of id proponents think he's
arguing for i think
so yeah i don't want to talk too much
about
james because i i still want to be able
to
work out something with him one-on-one
so that we can actually do a
presentation together where are you
based exactly
uh right now i'm in montreal yeah
but he's in texas let me know i can
maybe put you in contact but
yeah i i have to i have to wait till
kovid so i
he and i were talking in the past about
maybe doing something together he was
very hesitant
but in person and i wouldn't want to do
something online like this i would much
rather do something in person with him
if we do it because
he's a really nice guy if you're lucky
he'll have me over to his house for an
ending meal
it's pretty good his wife is indian and
man they're chilling out of spread
he's a good guy i think i think he's
opinionated and
um but a lot of scientists are
opinionated i think he's
kind of picked a fight with the origins
of the life community which is a little
bit um
he hasn't kind of picked a fight he said
some things that are just obviously not
not correct but let's be clear the
original life community is a very small
part of science
yeah he has not done the same thing um
with evolution to be honest
if you look at my interview on evolution
with him i mean
you know i did three interviews with him
if you look at the others
he he he actually came out very strongly
endorsing my book
yeah yeah well okay if you watch older
videos of him he's
he he does say some pretty absurd things
about yeah but you know
look at what the context was he was
saying is like hey i have some questions
i'm a scientist why can't you explain it
to me
and then no one has been wanting to show
up for me and it turns out that that's
true no one had really sat down and
talked to him like
like another scientist with respect and
act to explain things to him
i took him up on that and did that and
that changed so did i
what so did i yeah you did
i don't know when that happened but
there was a difference between i guess
being a non-scientist and a scientist
like um so if you had like for example
um
uh like a postdoc kind of talked before
um you know i'm
like i'm an hundred professor at
washington i'm not trying to say this is
everything i'm just trying to say this
guy
is an nsf-funded professor he has 600
like 800 publications
i have attempted that number of i can't
attempt that our publications when i
went
there's like a certain amount of like uh
i mean he deserves he deserves to be
respected on those questions and i think
and part of that is not just how you act
but it's also the messenger
i guess and so
anyways we built rapport through that
yeah
and i think a little different than what
he'd experienced
i mean i don't know when you talked to
him to be honest it was it was recently
it was like uh well yeah
anyway i think 2014 or so
so at that point she hadn't talked to
you right and so
yeah so you've heard about the stuff in
the past
a lot of that was just really informed
by the fact that he kept on asking
people
it's like okay so maybe everyone's true
can explain it to me and then they then
they treated him crazy like
so he he was reacting to that and
um i mean and that's that's
not gone well um i um
i have a lot of sympathy for him i think
that in a lot of ways uh
he find the descent from darwinism which
i i don't think was
a good idea to do and i think that
probably also something somewhat a wrong
way but i mean i'm sympathetic to him
because i think he was generally
ignorant and when he responded to me i
think he acted
truthfully like he wanted to learn and
he changed his points of view based on
things that i said and i don't think
that you can say that about a lot of
people
yeah i i so i feel like that descent
from darwinism thing
that was a phishing scam by the by the
discovery institute
and it screwed up people's careers
because there was an
actual ongoing like in the courts
culture war happening there
and it really screwed up like the the
scientific community was way too harsh
to people who signed that
um and it it just caused division
it was like that was a phishing scam it
was a fishing exam
that's how i see it that's i kind of see
him as a victim but then think about
what happened afterwards the scientific
community didn't actually really
deal with that well no they didn't they
didn't they weren't diplomatic
with that yeah and so you know
that burned bridge with him and and that
kind of pushed them into the ideas camp
and you know like i mean i talked about
left i i think that
he if he'll even say he's not he's not
arguing for id
he doesn't actually think that there's
there's a way to scientifically show
that
you know god's intelligence was involved
with something he preferred to be
talking about other things
yeah yeah and uh
and i think you know he but you know
here's the thing
he of all people of all people he's
already right to be heard even if he's
wrong
and so i i'm at a point where i'm at
peace with him saying stuff i disagree
with
and just realizing hey there's
disagreement in science and there's
going to be a lot of scientists that
disagree with him on this part but
there's actually some parts of what he's
saying that a lot of scientists will
agree on
and um that's just how science works
and i don't think we need to i don't
think we should be excluding him and i
don't think you are excluding him
i don't know no no i i i would like to
do a presentation with him
once once the coveted stuff's all
cleared up and i can travel from canada
to
you what's that what would you want to
talk about him about
well what i'd like to do is so his his
biggest concern
his okay some of his concerns i think
are completely
uh made up but some of his concerns are
legitimate
in that he he thinks that origin of life
research
is making too bold of claims like
they're overstating their case
that's probably true it well it
definitely happens in the media
as far as individual scientists doing it
like i definitely know
of i mean i could name a couple yeah he
he basically said that sawstack was
lying but notice he went and apologized
for that publicly
yeah yeah yeah so yeah he he has
apologized for some of the things that
he said
but the the uh
what would be fun to do is to with him
talk about what exactly we can say that
original life scientists
have discovered that's interesting and
what is it that he thinks is an
exaggeration it would just be
interesting to
to be like in front of an audience so
there's no nobody's playing with it
um you know no weird editing tricks or
something happening because
you know that's that's something he's he
said that has happened to him in the
past
and actually one of his videos that it
wasn't him who created it it was um
it was the discovery institute they
edited one of my videos to make it so
that it looked like i was saying that we
already discovered the origin of life
by completely cutting out a part of my
video where i have a big
red stamp saying this is not life like
they edited that part out
and put it together they spliced the
video together to make it look like i
was saying
in my video that we already discovered
it was absolutely absurd
and that was actually one of the things
that got me talking to him i was like
did you
do you know that this was edited that
way so um
our conversation actually kind of
started with like
hostility on that i was like do you know
this has happened and he
he's like i i did not have anything to
do with that
um but then he ended up actually being
an advisor on one of my animations so
i i feel like we're i feel like he and i
have an okay
um relationship at this point but we
haven't um
yeah we we never were able to set up a
a joint conversation together so the
part that he is really concerned about
in that space where you might be able to
do something is if you give him a script
for something
that really emphasizes the parts you
agree with him on and ask him to edit it
he might
he might actually uh
be up for that and also like you mean
there are places where it has been
overstated in the media you could pick
out some of those
oh yeah it's super obvious but but but
the same is true with every
field of science like how many times did
we cure cancer now
you know if you look at news headlines
yeah i think i think
i don't i don't entirely um like i mean
i think it makes a lot of sense
what's happened and what's going on
based in light of the history going back
to like the descent from darwinism what
happened there i mean if you get to know
him you'll find out
i mean it's really it's it's really a
tragedy
that it's turned into
into into this sort of thing because
he's a phenomenal scientist he
really is a great scientist and he's
done good work he continues to do good
work
and um he's not unreasonable he's
actually pretty reasonable i think that
there's uh i think that there's uh
there's just you know i mean i think
that there's been some mishandling of
household i mean there's not everyone
i mean science doesn't have like this
unified consensus on everything right
and when people disagree it doesn't mean
that one person's inside science and one
person's science that's scientists
sometimes it's just that there's two
scientists that are disagreeing
and um and that
even when people are questioning things
like evolution
and abiogenesis i think that we're
supposed to really hear those questions
you know that's what it comes down to i
think you have legitimate questions both
about evolution and
biogenesis early on um
that were not really received with
empathy
and i think that really set things down
a bad path
yeah i mean you know we talk about that
more often
but uh that and i'm also wondering
um what your
thoughts are on your discussions with
michael behe um
and you've had a bunch of them right
you've had
and um what like three or four public
conversations with him
yeah about that man yeah i mean and i
got some other stuff coming up with id
women adventure beckley
is doing an event with me this summer
with um
unbelievable again um
yeah i think it's it's interesting i
think that they don't
um i mean i think they've
been working through how to deal with me
because i'm not
their typical enemy right right and they
kind of deal with an awesome mentality
but i'm not their typical
enemy right so i don't know i mean
i think it's gonna be interesting to see
i mean i think they have one mode at
times it seems it's just attack but i
think
or don't attack occasionally but i don't
know i think they're still working out i
think
i think he'll probably never change his
mind yeah
but i'm convinced that he wouldn't ever
change his mind either because
people have have given spectacular um
responses to his arguments and he just
pretends like it didn't happen
it's it's really spectacular because
when he first came out like
i read his first i read his i've read
two of his books i read the first one
and i think the second one um
and the first one it seemed to me like
he was he legitimately thought that he
found
an issue with evolution i could see what
the issue
i could see that he was confused
then i saw people correct him i'm like
oh they corrected him exactly how i
would have
he's he seemed like a reasonable person
he should understand
why why this irreducible complexity
thing is not actually an issue for
evolution
but no he he like dug his heels in and
it was really disappointing for me to
see that because
i like it seemed out of character
what is interesting actually is that
almost none of these books
have a randomness have what proper
randoms
the place is really listed in the
streets i made on it i mean my cousin
around
i made mistakes in it i i find it really
to be telling i mean like if you're
going to make a controversial claim but
you can't actually acknowledge even
minor points you made errors and
i think that that should really be a
good sign to people listening and now i
do still enjoy talking to him
and i've enjoyed it partly because um
you know
uh you know it's
it still brings up really interesting
issues to talk about
i i agree too actually i i i liked
reading his first book
and you know we were talking earlier
about maybe the possible benefits
of the conflict between science and
evolution i think
michael would be a larger community i
mean like you know there's thousands and
thousands of people that watched my
exchange with him at texas a m right
right and um and like a lot of them
would never be exposed to a person
who was who could actually explain
evolution in like a coherent way and
also kind of emphasize the parts
that he believes that he emphasizes look
he has no problem with common descent
yeah yeah yeah he thinks there's a lot
of evidence for
common descent of humans and chimpanzees
and i had him publicly say that next to
me and we said this is the part we agree
on
yeah we don't put that and so i think
that's a little bit surprising for
people a lot of people argue that he's
not an evolutionist
and that's what he is right and then
also um you know
to point out you know why am i christian
to do this like most of them i've just
rarely been excused exposed to someone
who's credibly saying those things
yeah and so i think there's a real value
in that i mean i think it really serves
science i think it serves the common
good and you know even
it could serve idea in the sense that
even though it's a great idea they're
saying they're not a religious movement
and if this is that's what this is about
so
they should be glad about people kind of
trying to kind of separate those issues
for them
yeah uh that
i mean once you have an organization and
once you have a message
you just don't want to change you don't
want to steer the ship in a different
direction
i think that's just that's just human
nature that's
um and that's that's a that's a
consequence of large organizations
but the other thing that he had um
one of the benefits that i see in
michael behe's work is that
it it made so many people so irritated
that they that a lot of people a lot of
researchers paid a lot more attention to
how it is that protein complexes evolve
and i think i i don't know it's
impossible to tell
like now like how much of that was
because they were irritated with michael
behe but
there's been a lot of really great
research on the evolution of protein
complexes
and it actually does work in a different
it's
it's more like the evolution of
symbiosis than it is normal descent with
modification it's actually really
interesting how these
protein complexes when you've got
multiple proteins that are coming
together to form a
a macro machine basically like
how it is that that happens from an
evolutionary perspective it's really
interesting the the type of research
that's been happening
again i don't know if that was just in
the pipeline because now we can finally
study program
pipeline i mean a lot of this has to do
with the progress of technology i mean
most
people in science just don't even like
here's the thing i mean
this might be surprising but if you say
the name michael beahy to most
scientists they won't even know who he
is
yeah yeah so um well yeah that's
the the things that i see online are way
different than
the the things that scientists see ideas
outside
i mean the big thing for the nfce that
they struggled with is they were seeing
um all this stuff in the 90s and they
were concerned about the impact but
everyone was ignoring them
yeah yeah until the dover trial and the
kansas board appearing and then people
are like oh this could actually affect
education
you weren't lying and not actually got
it but think about is they were pretty
much ignored before that point
right and uh they're largely ignored
right now i mean
in the time now outside the scientific
community they're not ignored um
that's the difference so the fact that
they're irrelevant to scientists doesn't
mean they're irrelevant
to society right they're still pretty
relevant in the church
yeah and so yeah that's part of why
i thought it's important to not engage
with them because you know
there are i mean very few
people get an opportunity to actually
interact with scientists right
yeah especially if you're in a community
that's you know younger creationists
very few opportunities to do that so you
know that's kind of how i've
done some outreach but hey it's been
like three hours man we gotta get yeah
yeah yeah it was good yeah i
i just want to say that i appreciate
what you're what you're doing and that
you're gonna
talk about i really appreciate it yeah
so
yeah that's that's the book any any last
plug for the book
who do you think you should be reading
your book science if you want to oh yeah
peaceful science.com.org
yeah and check out the book and i'd love
to hear what you think about it i mean i
think there's a growing conversation
about some really interesting stuff
and i think uh you were right too that
it's not it's not a book that's very
different christians if you just want to
know
get the same science straight and think
about how to interact with things that
maybe you don't believe other people you
know about
believe and think about those together
and it's a fun conversation come join
us yep i agree well yeah thanks for
giving
giving your time here it was it was fun
we went down
every every possible road here so long
everyone
stay curious until next time uh i think
we're gonna i'm gonna try and
do more interview type podcast like
things
in the future so hopefully you like that